[Music]
welcome everyone to the football
tournament i'm shawn stacking the money
green with my partner pics ryan
real money kramer what's happening
creamdog sean i i
i lost the beard i'm a new man i did
clean shave and look
i'm coming for your units sean i figured
maybe the beard was getting in the way
of me
gobbling up your units here on the
football tournament the football
tournament of course presented by
mybookie.ag promo code tft
and all things comedy joining us as
always third man in the booth colby dan
aka the dantabase
aka pick dundee there we go ah look i
i was a little let down because you i
mean look you're kind of like you're
like roethlisberger
during during miami ohio days right now
oh no
you know like before was roethlisberger
current current times
back when he was exceptionally good
looking is that what you're trying to
say
colby dan thank you very much for the
compliment
i am ryan real money kramer and i'm
excited because the kramer gang
myself sean colby the pick dundee
yes uh whatever they call themselves we
get player props tonight guys
loving it yes that's true and of course
we have game
uh bets as well right now over at
mybookie.ag the san francisco 49ers
laying four and a half points against
the minnesota vikings
and uh we have the tournament going as
well so you got your bracket in you can
see how you're doing uh
it's not a bracket sean
sportsgamingpodcast.com
atc and again if you're watching this on
the all things comedy youtube
you're you're saying to yourself what
the hell is going on
we're gonna have a simulated madden game
the computer is gonna play each other
we're gonna bet on it we're gonna gamble
we're gonna do the play-by-play
trust us it's the way to go and uh
well you could you could have people
play the game but then they get
distracted they can't do the
play-by-play
it's also for nerds i guarantee you it's
more entertaining than an mls game oh
setting the bar high going after soccer
colby what's next
you need to attack the little league
world series sure michael uh sanderson
the youtube atc saying how do i wager
niners win it all
just go to mybookie.g promo code tft
and he said he's pouring his whiskey
again also we highly recommend
uh if you're someone who likes to drink
or procure in other uh
communities yeah
feel free to treat it as if this is your
nfl sunday sunday night football
whatever it is
feel free to catch a buzz it's certainly
uh we've discussed this sean i had this
epiphany the other day we crea we have
created an excuse
to quote work in front of football
when there's no football on yeah
and gamble and drink it's totally
acceptable that i'm out here drinking
whiskey
on a tuesday is today tuesday jesus i
don't even know
today is tuesday and uh big bets only 9
11.
seth is the breaking bad dude and uh
maybe he's talking about me
unclear oh is this person good looking
or not good looking are you
saying you're walter white well cause if
it's a good looking person
seth green is uh seth green
yes a lot of people uh confuse me with
seth green mostly because my name looks
like seth gray sean is much taller than
seth green all right
that's insulting that's the only solid
five eight and three
i like seth green man all right what are
we doing for the outfits today
uh colby you're the outfit man what are
we doing let's go classic let's go let's
let's bring it back
you know me and there's no excuse well
the vikings you can't really do anything
to save
you know what i mean i guess the gray
face masks but
you know oh here we go so we just go in
the 80s yeah let's go
that's perfect that's that's that's
flawless right it's a different gold i
like it
and now here's where you get you know
and sean i think the spread i
i don't know what the updated number is
i guess what is it four and a half
it was four and a half earlier yep it's
it's still four and a half which
candidly i was a little surprised it
tells me that the
the bookmaker mybookie.ag again used
that promo code tft
they are catching up with the updates
that we have been noticing over the past
couple weeks
uh where a this minnesota team's not so
bad but
but b you know i think so the way teams
are playing is changing
and maybe it's because it's playoff time
maybe because they know
it's easy to see a tide too this is the
football tournament
well and and also uh besides that
they're throwing in
the the player props the sweet player
props we'll be giving out some of those
as well
and uh yeah man it's just trust us again
if this is your first time
throw a couple bucks on it you will feel
alive you will feel those gambling
juices that you normally feel
when you're watching your fantasy team
your favorite team cash a sweet bet
uh joey mega million says are y'all
drinking yeah i'm drinking you know what
let's do it
cheers cheers good to see you again
shout out to the d-gen's over in the my
bookie madden twitch page
yeah pop over to the uh all things
comedy youtube give us a thumbs up say
what
introduce the uh the newly minted d gens
only over there
hashtag welcome thou neighbor
kramer i'm strong you have uh right now
you have the choice as far as what team
you want to bet on
we're uh throwing down two unit bet here
i'm currently
up two units on you i'm giving you the
choice because i think you won the last
game so what are you doing here
uh this is what we're using right yeah i
mean it's true
all the way around uh you know
with the number at four and a half sean
it seems to be
like they're trying to trick me
they're trying to trap me into taking
the san francisco 49er team
i won't be trapped give me kirk cousins
he's a different man
in he's now in the grid much like the
dude from that movie
he's escaped his life tron he's escaped
his family
and and the responsibility of raising a
child to go plug himself into a sim
world
kirk cousin realized with that day when
he couldn't even hit
the target of that gender reveal that it
was no longer
he was no longer fit for this planet
he's plugged himself into the grid
he's a much better man and oh by the way
did i mention i get harry
the hitman on my squad that's the real
reason why he's back in there yeah
wow that guy creates a ton of turnovers
that's going to be tough but
i'll talk myself into the 49ers lay in
four and a half perfect transition to my
player prop that i feel good about
george kittle over 62 receiving yards
cash that lock that up colby kramer what
are you guys uh doing for your uh
your official player props here all
right well look when they played the
saints just a week ago
we did this uh you know saints have a
great defensive line
so they kept throwing the screens to
dalvin cook all games
and then he got hurt yeah i'm gonna i
want to go over that dusty lines even
better so
not only am i taking the niners with
with stacking the money green over here
i'm also going to take dalvin cook over
five and a half receptions
you stole my action because we saw this
guy early enough and i'm terrified now
catching
i'm pulling the rip cord we are a kramer
gang we are not getting involved in
delving cook
we are evacuating that we're gonna prop
move on over
to mr kyle rudolph oh he he's the guy
that kurt cousins also
likes uh cousins a big fan of the tight
end much like sean
so for my viking prop give me kyle
rudolph
over five sean do you want to throw out
a second or should i just
should i just get crazy yeah throw it a
second the second prop that i like
because you know i like to grab a little
action on both sides here
i was on rahim mostert under last time
yeah i'm going back to that well we've
seen what this vikings
front seven can do yeah or is what is it
one eighteen
one eighteen and a half yeah throw me on
that as well let's go
baby how about how about debo samuel
under five and a half catches
all right i don't feel like he gets the
rock a lot keep throwing them out
sam gray on the atc youtube checking in
lego
49ers shout out to ace blazer
yeah ace players are checking in michael
uh sanderson saying the niners d
will dominate just like in real life the
niners defense is pretty solid but this
minnesota team especially these
more recent updates looks really good
but they have to go into san francisco
again
never watch these madden sims one quirk
is that we set the weather to random and
for whatever the case
the bay area seems to get more snow than
any of the other cold weather cities uh
global warming issues
like the snow comes in what was the
other city tennessee like tennessee yeah
yeah tennessee and and
and san francisco and oakland get all
the snow for some reason so
yeah it's uh game time is in one minute
uh oh wow the the most are uh under
moved to 115 are we moving
moving lines are we moving markets and
again uh go to
sportsgamingpodcast.com
see where you are in the leaderboard we
got our full schedule there
as well uh after tonight then uh we're
back next friday for the divisional
round
the rest of the division around playoffs
and then championship saturday
july 25th mark your calendar i'm sorry
sean did you say
championship saturday i did kramer
saturday
three o'clock on the west coast five
o'clock and then seven o'clock
three games back to back to back afc
championship nfc championship
and then of course the super bowl we're
going to be doing a uh
we're going to be doing a squares pool
for the super bowl as well so
much like if you were watching the
regular super bowl and you have like oh
i got seven and three
yeah you will be able to cash in on that
as well so again sportsgamingpodcast.com
atc kramer are we ready to uh kick
things off here
is uh is everyone ready because i'm
gonna i'm gonna progress here
we are controlling none of the teams as
it's saying you guys are idiots
confirmed shout out to brazen gator fan
just joe saying lol those snowy san
francisco days
sounds like he's on a hashtag team knows
beers
or at least uh you know showing you what
is a couple there you want to do a unit
on will there be uh
weather uh what wait what
i'm good i got my two unit bed i'm not
gonna waste the entire unit
on whether the weather i mean there's
there's always some weather in san
francisco
now whether it be wind which really
impacts these games snow we'll we will
see
well they say the coldest winter i ever
spent in life sean was the summer in san
francisco there you go
get your i wouldn't know of you from a
jar of vicks let's get this game
make sure you check out our jerry
glanville interview jerry glanville
episode was awesome and
of course sports gambling podcast
subscribe there we just recorded our
favorite uh
quarterback player prop bets for the
2020 nfl season
oh and i and i had fun with it yeah i
went i went even out past the season
sean
we talked cam newton we talked uh nick
foles got in there
russell wilson patrick mahomes trevor
lawrence
dean hogue 28 saying that their podcast
was great
snow in san francisco i told you we were
gonna get snow and i offered you an
opportunity to bet you
what the is this this is great the
bane never gets snow that's the best
well now the the interesting part is the
vikings they never see snow either
because they're a dumb team they're
coming from home
what will kirk cousins do captain kirk
under center to take
to get this game going hand it off to
dalvin cook
picks up a couple there three and and
let us know uh
how's the audio sounding everyone crisp
clear
no no richard gere oh man and of course
uh
let us know uh what are you betting on
what do you like tonight
and and if you missed the start of the
game don't worry they have live in-game
wagering
my bookie daddy promo code tft cousins
under center
second and seven from their own 28 back
to throw
checks it down to rudolph there we go
baby
one one catch so far for kirk or for
kyle rudolph
third and one though the dangerous third
and one
rudolph in the snow seen this before
right
leading leading captain kirk slay oh
look at you is that what you called
santa growing up you
nerd third and one vikings out of the
shotgun the enterprise is here
cousin play action oh no faces pressure
oh oh
incomplete that's it it was a third and
one you know how it is i forgot i had to
go full junkie
shout out to the chat for reminding me
that i'm a junkie michael in the uh
atc youtube i lived in northern
california 18 years and it's never
snowed in san francisco
but i like the twist for the gambling
aspect hashtag
vikings at the punt on fourth and one
decent punt
oh this is great got it at the 15.
stays on his feet picks up a couple give
the guy a block man he makes a juke
come on 49ers will take over first and
ten on their own 20.
how's the audio in your ear sean it's
delightful
it's a real treat wow you read my mind
with that word
and uh spread the word appreciate you
guys spreading the word maybe we'll do
some uh
give out some 25 dollar free plays free
play
jimmy g out of the shotgun first and 10
from the 20 back to throw
has time has time checks it down
he didn't get two feet in completely
incomplete coming out in the gun not
what i was expecting
very aggressive i guess they are a run
first team the kyle shanahan uh 49ers
kendrick's had a big game last time too
man oh he did and
the vikings created a ton of turnovers
we'll see if that continues tonight
jimmy g under center second and 10 from
the 20.
hands it off here we go that's
hitman harry you're not going to get too
many freebies like that
uh he was coming in for for a serious
kill shot uh
do you know chuck norris has nightmares
of harry the hitman
harrison smith is just a beast in this
game and he creates a ton of fun
ton of fumbles i formation now third and
one last time we saw him four force
fumbles
five passes defending oh play action at
jimmy g rolls out has time
completes it to the rookie brandon ayuka
as arizona state i gotta be honest it's
hard to see with the shades with the
snow
i'm getting a little a little white out
there is a white out in san francisco
first and ten from the 45 they blitzed
hitman harry on that play good pickup
well it looks like the snow is melting
rapidly i'm curious to see if we'll have
snow in the second half
hard count by jimmy g it's like debo
samuel in motion
hands it off to mostar and he gets lit
up
again this looks right like from the
1970s where they just
were allowed to like slam their forearm
into dudes heads
those are everything that's illegal
about tackling now harrison smith does
haunting beautiful it's beautiful i hate
to be on the opposite side of a
warrior like that and the regression's
coming he's now over two
oh for two separating the ball hands it
off to mostert
nothing there he's back after
after gaining nine yards on his first
carry sean he's back down to seven
yeah looking good so far very early on
the most
under rushing yards third and twelve
and again if you're just tuning in you
can go to mybookie.ag use that promo
code tft and bet the game live
they have live updated numbers as the
game goes along jimmy g
out of the shotgun third as well from
the 43 play action
has time they pick up the blip up uh no
no no no he got it he got it
challenged let's go kurt vikings take
over on their 43 first and ten play
action by kirk spin move right
turn around there we go god dammit it's
so annoying this guy sucks when they
when they have their guy beaten they
just don't turn they don't have the
awareness down
it's almost like it's a video game
regardless joey bosa should have had the
sack there
second and ten good start for under
bettors we bet the under
you're liking this under gang feels
relaxed already
although there's only there's still 10
40 left to go in the first hand it off
the cook gets to the
outside not much there it's certainly
looking like
colby has put the early mush on cook's
involvement
in the passing game five and a half you
know
yeah i'll panic after the first quarter
okay you know luke
guy in the atc youtube says damn i
always remember that san francisco snow
kirk out of the shotgun third and eight
delayed handoff to devil cook as a hope
the middle
and down he goes minnesota getting
conservative getting soft
kramer you can't like that as a vikings
backer no i i'm okay where we are right
now is that a shuffle pass
and for those wondering where the snow
is coming from in san francisco i mean
you want to talk about an og nose beer
city
where they they had the progressive
thought process to say
what if they're just not for the they're
not only for the nose
[Applause]
[Laughter]
early adopters do uh no spears oh what a
i said what if
what if your was your nose
shout out to south park magic man blanco
huge friend of the program checking in
cheers bro lewd legend there
first and ten at the eighth that's where
the 49ers and jimmy g will take over
seeing their breath can we see some
results on this drive
split eye jimmy g under center first and
ten
hands it off to mostert again nothing
going on
kramer you mentioned it pregame this
vikings uh defense this front seven
showing up uh yeah and that's the trick
if you want to get you to be able to
play some defense in the back end
because jimmy gia accidentally has some
throws from time to time but i think at
the end of the day if you can
force jimmy g to be the reason they got
to beat you
you know snow on the ground i don't know
jimmy g's got a big nose he might be
distracted
huge hole up the middle by most come on
bro
force a fumble stop dancing harrison
smith lights him up again but moses gets
a
hearse down first 20. how has he not
dropped the ball here
we're like barely into the game right
now he's already got a blast he's coming
in with he's i mean he's straight up
firing de-cleaning people every single
time
shots are hitting the ground the shells
are hitting the ground you hear the
cases
does his nephew work for the company i
don't know how you're doing this on a
consistent basis
hand off to mostly again trying to
establish that 49er ground game
second and six i want to give a special
shout out to mark wade who says let me
get a shout out from the best commentary
crew in the game
oh mark wade checking in on the my
bookie madden twitch page
he's a big friend of the program awesome
dude
jimmy g out of the shotgun second and
six
again double tight end set hands it off
to mozart breaks on the outside
oh
that's another 49ers first down dude
that could have been like a 20 or 30
yard run
stay stay vertical evan logano checking
in on the atc
youtube snow the san francisco treat you
got that right
they love the snow here
jimmy g out of the shotgun first and ten
from the 31 bubble pass that
was that that was horrific he's one for
four
15 yards and a pick well
we love making fun of jimmy g on this
show
uh and he's he's kind of just laying an
egg right now at home
this is the divisional round of the
playoffs one of these teams is going to
move
on to the nfc championship game maybe
he's got the rona they were all
quarantined
and maybe that porn star snuck into the
hotel
deep ball down the sidelines drops it in
now that's a throw
jimmy g in the vikings
that is uh oh yeah devo samuel correct
no no no i think oh
sorry travis benjamin beautiful samuel
still that's weird
that's all colby cares about i love it
it's all about the props baby i love the
player props
shout out to my bookie for putting up
the props jimmy g under center first and
ten from
38. delayed play action
good blocking he's got a nice ball to
the outside kennel keeps his feet in
let's go 49ers we got this dude
run the offense nate
moontron is uh throwing some hate in the
youtube atc
come on nate give it a chance we're
gambling on madden we're having a couple
of beers i think if you watch it you
will enjoy it
i mean talk all the you want you
can bet on niners the niners right now
minus five and a half
i mean what do you got better going in
life right now you know what i mean
my niners minus nine and a h i'm sorry
niners minus five and a half over at
mybookie.ag use that promo code tft
we have snow in san francisco or if you
like the vikings maybe you want to take
that plus 175 money line
that means you bet a hundred dollars you
win 175 on this beautiful video game
it's a tie game right now
and one of these teams has harry the
hitman we got ourselves a game here
in san francisco die that's that's some
arm talent there
from the fullback is that a fullback no
no no they're on defense right
linebacker
special teams looking i mean
that's more armed talent than i don't
know if you saw the picture i tweeted
out matt ryan no arm talent in madden
21.
jimmy g hands it off and nothing doing
there most dirt he's had eight carries
only 31 yards they're trying to get that
49er run game going just haven't had
much luck
you were on the under on what was that
number one something one one sixteen
or something and a half wow dave
1970 saying this is a video game no dave
this is this is real life and uh it
feels real when you have
money on it jimmy g out of the shotgun
third and eight
plenty of time checks it down underneath
the most dirt
can't do much there they're gonna have
to settle for a field goal
fourth and five one it's disappointing
start
i mean that was a good drive that one
dude pointing out that kendricks is the
only one that can cover kittle perhaps
that's the difference
in this offense uh fook guy
oh no checking in saying get kiddle more
involved couldn't agree more
i'm sitting on that over 62 receiving
yards he had that nice ball
missed it field goes up and it's good
san francisco
scores first if you bet san francisco to
score first you already cashed a bet at
my bookie
man interesting start to this game these
snow games can get ugly we'll see if we
see some big plays later on
kramer as soon as you see an updated
line let me know
just joe saying i just missed football
good graphics good folks
thank you joe i agree we also miss
football
and we missed gambling on football
that's why we created
the football tournament yeah i mean this
is what happens right when
when when when the world changes right
new industries pop up
we've gotten really good at making sure
your uber eats driver isn't eating your
fries in the way to your house right
that's that's a great improvement in
delivery going forward
uh people aren't going to be going to
grocery stores as much anymore i have to
imagine
that's beautiful i pull up they just
drop in the back of my truck
you know and we create football that's
it sometimes people are creators and
sometimes they're just
followers that sit on their ass and
don't do a god damn thing
when the world is having a crisis shout
out to us
for solving this problem for everyone
here we're
this country needs leadership right now
when we're providing it we're creating
new industries
yeah now the entire entire industry does
this show
we're making football great again
cousins out of the shotgun first and ten
hand it off to david cook
nothing there with these hits from harry
the hitman we're making football great
who's sitting on a nice under ticket
right now you got to be relaxed yeah if
you bet the under 49
you're feeling great got to be relaxed
minnesota vikings actually the only team
one of the two teams to ever play a
tuesday night football game
i know because i went to that game boom
eagles
vikings joe webb came in as a 14-point
underdog why was that at two zillion
uh they they had snow and they and they
moved it to tuesday
and this also had it was week 17 if i'm
not mistaken right
did this not or maybe it was six they
had this had implications in the super
contest if i recall
because the spread moved to shitload
yeah
and uh my dad just drunk is all hell
just screaming throw it to the white guy
there we go oh you get a screwdriver
breaks the tackle gets to the outside
stop him now guys i need
yards i need uh reception it's not yards
he just went over his yardage in one
case yeah
he picked the wrong one colby damn it
dalvin cook with a great screenplay
they run the screenplay all the time
and it doesn't work like that
do it again same side of the third yeah
same play
same play why why change it cousins
and that's intercepted huge
[Applause]
he's so bad jimmy g under center first
and ten from the 33.
i gotta i gotta go shades play action
oh cramer
oh no every once in a while
every once in a while kramer forgets to
uh hit the play you know
to keep it from going to a sleep mode
hitman harry with the sack though but no
fumble guy
has not generated a fumble split eye
chat's going to be so in jimmy g
under center chats are so angry hands it
off
oh and he tries to take mozart's head
off again
all right kind of hesitated that most
are you know moser was able to pick up
eight yards third and 12.
you need to hire someone to push the
button you've been exposed that
uh they're saying third and twelve
exposed
who's on the sticks jimmy g out of the
shotgun
third and twelve big three down for this
49ers team
checks it down underneath to uh oh oh he
breaks the tower go
go this is that uh
that taylor guy that we we really didn't
i honestly i didn't really know this kid
until he started watching these sims and
the recent update he's been involved
love not seeing samuel involved look at
that breaks
taylor the nice yak yard after catch
shout out to big boy in the twitch chat
it's snowing in san francisco baby
jimmy g back to throw again play action
deep down the middle
oh wow is he trying to keep it in play
that was odd
that's not a volleyball what the
are you doing that was samuel though
okay
samuel got a hand on it for some reason
don't try catching that he was trying to
like tip it back
you know he's trying to do like a
backhanded one odell beckham man
i'm telling you oh you can trace all
this nonsense odell and kanye
that's where things started going awry
in society handed off the most sir picks
up a handful there now and no one's
using two hands anymore
most just gonna he's got 40 no regard
for the fundamentals
i i know this is not a good start for
the under mozar bet
third and seven from the 24. great bet
uh great surfer
last play of the quarter got to be right
and we're always advocates of the first
quarter under
one madden sims one more play to sweat
jimmy g completes it to trent
taylor again and that's good we got we
got to learn more about this guy i
i don't know what the hell his deal is
and he's stealing all kindles yards
louisiana tech kid skip holtz was his
college coach
east carolina ties so you know he's he's
a saint
i mean and as sean just pointed out if
you if you listen to the sports gambling
podcast you watch any of these sims
first and third quarter that's where you
pound the under but overall like game
under gang has to be relaxed as
even i have no faith that san francisco
can score a touchdown
jimmy g hands it off to mozart again
only picks up a yard there bringing up
second to nine
now mostert has 43 yards he doesn't have
a great game
but they've given it to him 11 times
well oh man i'm regretting taking kirk
cousins in a prime time spot sean
cooper wilkinson saying who cut the most
dirt
i like that that's a classic dad joke
most sir
nothing right nothing again third and
nine i'm telling you this is
uh can i can i go out on a limb and say
interception loading
interception loading i'm gonna say
kittle you gotta throw it you're in the
red zone give it to kittle
taylor touchdown i'd be fine with that
shout out to yates blows guys he only is
watching us because he got banned from
every other streaming channel
that's impressive jimmy g back to throw
out of the shotgun third and nine
oh and down he goes hangs on to the ball
is he at field goal range anymore i
don't know
that's a 42 yarder now right 40 yards it
seems like wind is the only
thing that really messes up these field
goals do we know if there's wind the one
punt this direction was short of the end
zone
that's true this is a 39 yarder come on
they don't miss
they don't it's robbie gold right he
doesn't miss
field goals up well there's wind and
it's good there's wind
six nothing here in san francisco ugly
game so far but
hey exciting because the spread well
within i mean we're clearly the better
team
we should be up by a lot more yeah well
then sean uh if you want to get involved
head over to mybookie.ag use that promo
code tft
the live number 49ers minus a touchdown
minus 450 on the money line 38 is the
total the vikings money line
is plus 225.
okay you know i'm feeling uh i'm feeling
pretty good like colby said we have been
the better team
minnesota had that one drive going we
picked them off
i feel like our defense is playing
pretty solid we just need to convert
some of these red zone opportunities i
mean even that one drive was really one
reception
yeah just that one uh yeah just
basically that one dalvin cook play has
been their entire offense
dalvin cook with one reception after the
first quarter i feel all right there you
go
right you know you could look at that
the other way sean there's definitely a
win he
kicked that to the 10-yard line down he
goes
at the 30-yard line and that's where
they'll uh take
over first and ten from their thirty
perfect spot to call a screen first and
ten
i love colby's advocation for crap like
screenplays
defensive holding just get cooked the
ball all right cousins out of the
shotgun first and ten from the 30.
he's a modern-day metcalf delayed
handoff to dalvin cook nothing there
this is the wrong team to get cook two
involved
got to get him i mean to your point they
do need to get him involved in the
passing game out on the edge yeah
that's where he can break some tackles
you saw it before i mean he's their
leading receiver right now
that's what i would try to do at least
you know a sim god like myself
rudolph only one catch in the first
quarter that's all right cousins out of
the shotgun second to ten
from the third he's split out wide he's
he's going to him right now
yep oh wow rudolph went up got his hands
on it couldn't pull it down
got the target only two completions for
cousins in the first quarter
the total is now down to 38 sean so
maybe this is
this is maybe when do you look to bet
that live over kramer 30
a pretty key number but deluxe picks it
was pick dundee
it scares me because of the snow but we
say the snow is not important it's the
win that's important
cousins back to throw third and ten has
time
joey posted getting around here
come on he sheds joey bosa but down or
sorry nick bosa
and it's uh eric armstead that makes the
tackle right gets the sack
just joe pointing out the graphics are
good enough that while you're baked it
looks pretty real
shout out to being baked god damn it
this is not maybe
you gotta hop on the over soon well
let's try and
drum up some scoring possibly we throw
out uh some free play kramer
next touchdown scored yeah let's do next
touchdown we get a first touchdown
scored
first touchdown scored we will be giving
out uh what do we want to do 25
free points over my bookie.g promo code
tft make sure you signed up
if it's harry the hitman let's go 50.
all right if he scores a touchdown
wow i like it i like it no i don't like
it because i got 49.
you can throw a bounty on someone jimmy
g
under center first and ten play action
deep down the middle of the field what
the
you know it's good triple t what are you
doing
samuel so i'm okay with the incompletion
37 it's down to 37 sean we're monitoring
the situation with this total
what is he thinking we can't go much
lower
can anyone read those signs that they
have in the standards snow is basically
melting off the field i i don't think
it's going to be an issue in the second
half right
jimmy g out of the shotgun second and
10. still coming down a little bit
though
back to throw from his own 27. completes
it to trent taylor
the sim guy and he doesn't force a
fumble again
these guys are clearly standing up with
a little cte
he's an amazing slot receiver
can we get the uh independent
neurological expert to
start evaluating these people he's he's
most of their offense right now split
eye
65 yards jimmy g under center first and
ten
hands it off again a little bit of a
hole there for most he's gonna hit that
over dude
why do you say that i just believe it
because you're negative energy
that's why
well you are on the viking so yeah i'm
rooting against you in life right now
hit stick harry is is bringing some heat
and uh i'm worried
that he's going to be generating a
fumble here soon it feels like he's due
right
jimmy g under center second and four
play action again has time deep down the
middle airing it out
damn it and he pulls it in damn it
that's what i'm talking about
are you wait what team are you on
samuel catches so i mean i guess i'm
still okay with that one but
i need him i need that to be his only
catch of the half
put it like that how of all the
guy i mean is that the rookie
[Applause]
just run the ball look you got to have
fun with it you know what i mean
gotta have fun with it
john mcdeerman saying because of your
negative energy
classic jimmy g out of the shotgun
from the three let's put it in baby
to the end zone he's got his man
samuel now he's back on pace
i guess i can't complain cause i'm on
the niners but i mean
five and a half now he's at two a lot of
time left in the second
god damn it this game's over i picked
the wrong side
oh yeah x points up and it's good
and now the 49ers up 13
points here i think i picked the wrong
side sean
well there's no wrong side when it comes
to the best online sports book
mybookie.ag promo code tft
you're a pro sean thank you that's why i
get paid
the live number oh wow look at
jesus is that what it takes to be a pro
kramer what's the experience 49ers minus
10 over in my bookie.ag plus 200 for the
vikings moneyline 37 still the total
well here's the deal uh we just scored a
touchdown first one of the game we said
we're going to give a 25
free play out we will be giving it out
just sending a
send in a photo of your setup where you
got it up on the tv the laptop
maybe you got two laptop screens going
drinking some beers doing whatever
sending a photo of your setup watching
the football tournament and tag us at
gamelan podcast
at gambling podcast and we will pick a
winner and give you guys a 25
free play cousins is due for a fumble
stop it
he's due for a pass down the field i
mean
it's not like we're playing the 85 bears
first and ten cousins out of the shotgun
not having a great game so far we're up
to 42
now the total is 42. first and ten from
the 19 here we go
up the middle that was a pass right no
you really want that uh over catches
first and 10 at the 42. dalvin cook with
a clear
handoff there by the quarterback i
thought he just just chucked it out
there just a tiny bit
you know what i mean like uh john
mcderry wants to know can
he send a photo of his jerk station
oh well you know honestly that might be
the same station
like jerk meat or uh
on your laptop so yeah i think there's
going to be some cross over there
although ideally you wouldn't be using
your jerk station while watching the
game but again
some people are bigger fans than others
and hey
uh you know ryan looking pretty good in
the sunglasses so whatever
whatever is your company listen if
you're if you're
cranking it to anyone you're definitely
cranking it to me so lawrence trent
saying how is it snowing in san
francisco
[Applause]
we put the weather on random wild stuff
happens
dalvin cook picks up two second and
eight
people acting like uh like it's snowing
in san francisco
or something la liga
throw us a thumbs up over at the youtube
atc
49ers need to do something to stay in
this game i think he's talking about the
vikings there
no i think they start with the niners he
sees the onslaught coming from oh no oh
yeah here we go
[Applause]
both tackles got shredded d ford from
penn state dee's nuts you like that kirk
you like that
just blows by the right tackle just
no respect for kirk cousins tosses him
to the ground like a rag doll
wow seems like cousins out of the
shotgun delayed handle
the ground team no belief in kirkland
these they must be listening to
our podcast kramer because they don't
believe in kirk cousins
not letting him throw the ball down
field on third and 15.
john mcdeer and saying you guys are
awesome no you're awesome john
especially if you're uh supporting the
podcast
shout out to beau weiss who's in the in
just hopped on
bo vice of course the man who gifted us
this amazing drop
[Applause]
but yeah listen bo uh we'll excuse the
tardiness this time but let's try to be
a little bit more
prompt and set a good example for
everyone else all right
but hey even if you're like bo you're
just tuning in just seeing this on
youtube whatever it is
and now uh you still have a chance to
bet on the game because that live number
it changes every play jimmy g out of the
shotgun first and ten bullet pass
completes it out of the backfield the
most are
not much there this guy's a bum and
remember we're giving away 25
free play tweet in a photo of your setup
tag us at gambling podcast so we know
uh yeah so we can give you the 25 free
play
and sean while you're while you're
following us on twitter you should also
check out the sports gambling podcast
slack space oh
yeah that's a fun place to hang out
jimmy g oh
god he tried to throw the game he tried
to throw an interception that was
who was it bar anthony bar dropped that
that was a touchdown baby
jimmy jesus christ
uh raphael says i'm in england it's 1 40
a.m
shout out to that guy i got work in five
hours i don't understand american
football what am i doing here
jimmy g smith move and down he goes
huge sack by hunter there nell hunter
who really showed out last year throwing
up the fade away
michael sanderson explaining what are
you doing here justin joy
root for red raphael
appreciate you checking in overseas you
can bet on these simulated video games
i'll explain to you who's winning but
again uh it's pretty easy just go to my
bookie
proco tft get yourself a little wager
and you might have a shot here
my book is not a g might i add yes
all right well let's uh pick six
infinite gold explaining american
football to
rafael saying it's 5 42 in california
usa
football is a very gnarly game some
people have died on the field
this actually makes me want to watch
football more first and ten cousins out
of the shotgun from the 47.
back to throw his time over turnover
deep
checks it down short two he gets blown
up there oh come on man picks up one
osbourne
osborne the buffalo transfer went to
buffalo for three years they went down
to miami last year
thought he was going to be a big deal
they were uh they underachieved great as
we used to say
f the u yes yes
cousins out of the shotgun second to
nine from the 47.
[Applause]
back to throw has time checks it down
here
that's my guy getting those dink and
dunk catches again
you know me a big private school
guy sean you know it
cook was open too he was further up the
field a little disappointed by that uh
decision by
by kirk listen bro at this point you
just got to own the fact that you you're
mush i'm at one
you're still very much alive cousins out
of the shotgun third and four
from the 42. back to throwing the screen
boom completes it to cook turns up field
juke move for a first down
what up mr mush huh we got this
we got this first and ten two for 55.
he's our leading receiver he's talking
all right we have a winner here
and it's uh sam i am on a twitter
congrats you just won a 25
free play nice love giving out the free
play
sean thought i saw a fall start there
keeping it on the ground putting away
the whistle look at this under it's just
kind of locked
i mean dalvin cook's been fairly
effective actually in the rushes yeah
considering the team they're playing
he's had a couple where he's been
stuffed for no game
too so 10 rushes for 50 yards not too
shabby
and and if you're a vikings fan you
gotta you have to have that or you're
just terrified every time cousins drops
back with the way that their tackles
have been taken to school
hands it off to cook again second and
three good defense by the 49ers
and what better way to slow down in edge
rush
of d-ford and bosa then keep running
cook up the middle on those delayed
shotgun runs
third and two from the 27.
vikings vikings need to get a touchdown
here if they want to stay in this game i
feel like if they settle for a field
goal here they're going to be in trouble
here we go cousins out of the shotgun
third and two
cook the lone back
and they call the screen again catch it
incomplete
nearly intercepted kirk cousins
5 for 10 for 67 yards 55 of those yards
have gone to dalvin cook
he's got to hold onto the ball for like
a second longer let cook get out into
the flat
didn't do that he's a what can i
say here comes
a long what is this wow this is a four
it's a uh yeah 44 yard field goal from
the right hash
it's up and it's good minnesota cuts the
deficit to
10. kramer how are you feeling about
your vikings right now
i'm feeling just fine we're it feels
like we should be down more
and and shout out to uh to anyone who's
listening or watching us on the
don't be ashamed
yeah i've been there before you know
what you know that's the whole point
right you got hulu on your phone
whatever you're watching you got you got
youtube on your phone you're betting on
this which means you got action on this
which means you don't want to miss it
which means why not combine
two euphoric sensations gambling on
sports and taking a
i watched rocky two once on the
i'll be honest wow the entire movie
i don't think i don't think doctors
would recommend that i have a confession
i once
beat the entire game boy mario on
one session on the shutter what legs
were fully asleep
is this recently probably 30
49ers will take it out of the end zone
20 down to the
23. i get in trouble at sometimes
oh looks like someone's clutching their
country there
i wasn't number 19 though that was 13
huh sean shout out to formula one been
getting into the uh the old racing
the racing cars shout out to jerry
glanville who's 78 years old still
racing
yeah we had clanville on the podcast
that's a must listen
from what i gather the uh the the racing
european racing folks
look at nascar like it's uh yeah the
inbred cousins yeah
jimmy back to throw another dangerous
throw
that was the same you're telling me you
only turned one way the whole time
[Laughter]
like if you don't know jerry glanville
he's just a gem
he's just a 78 year old former football
coach
who still races cars for some reason it
was an awesome interview american
treasure
jimmy g out of the shotgun empty set
second and ten
running the two-minute drill trying to
get some more points beforehand
pull it pass
[Applause]
not been involved at all sean let's head
over to mybookie.ag promo code tft
it's still nine and a half the niners
are laying the points here nine and a
half point favorites
the vikings are now three to one on the
money line which is still intriguing
considering only a ten point game the
total now thirty nine and a half
jimmy g out of the shotgun third and
four
has time checks it down to kill what are
you doing
where's your awareness sean yes
don't be too loud or zach might hear you
rooting for george
he's he's still he's 23 receiving yards
he needs 62 for his total i should have
won catches
when you didn't put him in your top ten
fantasy
tight ends last year you made a
statement now you're
flip-flopping you're rooting for george
kettle shout out
shout out to jeff stanton who's asking
when the minnesota golden gopher college
experience episodes dropping
i think that's a great question very
very soon
if it's not the one dropping tonight
it's dropping tomorrow i believe it yeah
i believe it's tomorrow d marshall
saying walter payton race cars
a little uh known fact about walter
payton also a huge gun nut and we had
jim mcmahon
on and if you remember uh there was like
a uh
chicago vice uh poster that mcmahon did
with walter payton and
they actually used walter payton's uzi's
for the photo shoot
apparently he had a trunk full of guns
first and ten
cousins out of the shotgun completes it
underneath and now the vikings three
timeouts one minute left to go
is it me or does kirk cousins look like
scared back there
yeah that's the cousins he was twitching
he's twitching
i mean his whole career he's kind of
been like that right
you know he's going to be one of these
guys when we look back on his career
we're going to be like
that was not so bad he just he's but
he's never a guy in the moment that you
want to have money
you know in many ways he's like the
bizarro eli man no no we're gonna it's
gonna be very sam bradford
like because we're gonna look back and
be like he wasn't so bad but he made a
ton of money
cousins back to throw yes completes the
cook
i mean stays in bounds they use their
other timeout colby there you go
there's your third dalvin cook catch the
whiskey's getting better
you know as the game goes on there you
go colby
this will be interesting who who starts
with the ball in the second
you half that's a good question the chat
will answer you i'm sure shout out to
dean hogue who says listen to the
glamville one while i was at the weed
store
wow that's a long you spent a lot of
time now sir
cousins out of the shack in person 10
from his own 44.
yes that's he's it no that's an
incomplete pass
second and 10. i think he stepped out of
bounds challenged it
yeah it's not a catch
a little challenge actually are they
playing like salsa music what's going on
in san francisco no idea
cousins out of the shotgun second and 10
40 from his own 44 52 seconds left to go
back to throw completes it to rudolph oh
hold on
there we go there you go in the 49ers
territory
now a knocking on the door of field goal
range are they going to get a score
before half cut this to seven points
and this is this is the ultimate dagger
drive if they can get in the end zone
forget about it oh they can make this a
one score game but right now
with the timing i'm at this point i'm
just hoping for
10 yards cousins out of the shotgun
first and ten
that's almost in a strange way this sets
up a better timing scenario
yeah where they they gain a little bit
of yardage they get into
field goal range they don't it up
the only way they this up is kirk
cousins
drops back takes the sack they use the
timeout and then they run the clock out
on the next play
i feel like i just outlined what was
gonna happen cousins out of the shotgun
right there come on checks it down and
it's intercepted by richard sherman
and that's this cousin's second
interception oh the first
unbelievable duty that cook wide open
now san francisco has three timeouts 17
seconds are they going to try and get in
the field goal range
go holster gets in the outside okay they
use the timeout colby's showing everyone
how to call timeout yeah you got to get
into these games
you know i don't care that it's not me
not me
[Applause]
i'll do the spike sign you know what i
mean because
jimmy g under center most huge hole i
didn't see 41. he blended in with the
snow
see this is what's so annoying because i
have mastered under rushing yards
but i also have 49ers laying for that
that's cooked john
yeah i think and especially if they have
a lead they're just gonna pound it
they have six seconds left and one
timeout i think you need to get a little
closer i i don't
i don't feel safe with a 57-yard field
goal here no they're into the weather
yeah into the wind they're into the one
just take a shot
right they're doing it they got trips
you but you have timeouts also so do it
one time out
quick quick first and ten rounds gotta
throw right rock it right here
what's he doing still okay i got another
shot no i think he i think you try the
field goal
i don't think you can win now i don't
think you hit it but i'd much rather the
field goal attempt than
another hail mary that's i say hail mary
man
no you have a better ch a 57 yarder it's
gonna be tough he threw that right away
those receivers got down the field quick
49ers not going to elect to kick the
field goal
no this is the right this is the right
goal but that's a that's a bad call
uh i mean what was that fast
interference well then you got to go for
the end zone so now i agree it's a trash
call
trash call from a trash quarterback
jimmy g
i say it because i love you jimmy and
now that brings us to half time
niners start with the ball oh man kramer
you got to be you got to be worried
i'm in a little bit of trouble here
green gang is relaxed here
but here's what i'd say nothing going
right for the minnesota vikings
only down 10 points well and nothing
going right for the minnesota vikings
only down 10 points
and certainly that four and a half is
just begging for that back door
because you could see them scoring that
garbage touchdown to make it a
three-point game
the back door is always open when you
have a quarterback like jimmy g there's
a little bit of alex smith in there
remember we used to call him uh backdoor
alex or whatever yeah cause he would
just
he would never be able to just they
never they fall asleep on the couch they
never forget to lock the back door and
and
eventually it might not happen today it
might not happen tomorrow
someone's gonna bust through this but at
some point someone's gonna bust in your
home and you better be hoping you're
sleeping on your back
if you know what i'm saying has this
happened to you before kirk cousins no i
sleep on my back
kirk cousins 29.7 qb ratings
that is horrible that's not good eight
for 16. two interceptions
all of his receiving yards going to uh
dalvin cook nothing
nothing going well here i mean this is a
rare like if you took both overs for the
running backs you're feeling pretty good
not a position look at this only three
guys have a carry not a position we
often see these sims
yeah yeah putting people in so you're if
you're what i'm talking about right
there
three catches for mr dalvin cook that's
your guy three catches for mr
kyle rudolph we're both on the right
path for our
samuel only with two problems so look at
her right there
and uh you know kittle not doing much
and not
you know other who had the long catch
was that debo
yeah unbelievable i still can't believe
that happened
hmm and the other the other part of this
game that's a little unbelievable is
harry the hitman
not for seven tackles seven tackles
seven of them
are eight tackles seven solo and a sec
seven solo and
no no separations from the ball does he
even have a pass to fight
on a great game though no past offended
no forced fumbles
this has to regress in the second half
it has to
yeah he's gonna get a turnover no one
has more than three solo tackles harry
the hitman's got seven
uh yates blows guys saying my blood
alcohol content is higher than kirk's
quarterback rating okay yeah if you're
if you're sitting like a .27 uh yeah
okay
that's uh you shouldn't be operating in
a vehicle but that is
no goes anywhere anymore this is the
world i mean i i don't want to sound
good but we're gonna operate like a
pontoon boat
i'm enjoying like i'm enjoying the the
the i have
the ultimate excuse never to leave my
house this is my dream scenario sean
yes as a uh as a borderline hermit
cramer this is
the covent has been a dream scenario i'm
driving my car just so the gas doesn't
spoil
[Laughter]
all right california is uh california
king saying just got home from work
cracking open my first beer warming up a
box of porto's
meat pies oh that's a local reference
yeah why why are you
why are you throwing that how does
everyone know porto's button but me
how do you know this is delicious how
have you lived in los angeles and don't
know about portos
i don't i don't know buddy i guess
you've been on the west side the whole
time but even then it's like it's it's a
it's an
la staple you want to get cuban you want
to get a nice cuban sandwich
a beige some sort of something from a
bakery i mean i like a good cuban
sandwich but i don't go out of my way
for a cuban sandwich you know what i
mean
i mean you've never been to porto's
that's why okay okay i would say if
you're a sandman
being a sandwich man the fact that
you've never eaten a porto sandwich
is a little bit disrespectful to the
city that you call home well i've done
mario's
cause i would say this i would put
porto's
porto's has to be in a top ten sandwich
okay
in my opinion no now now now you're now
you're talking uh
if we're if we're doing holistically a
sandwich
yeah they have great bread they have
great meat options uh
it's it's i mean sean you can back me up
here but it's
it's i mean bay cities higher on that
list
they said he's all about the bread but
we're talking about the same universe
okay we're talking we're talking about
the same gallons okay kramer speaking of
sandwiches can you pull up that
photo of bill belichick on her instagram
page all right
it's gold phillips french dip that's
what that's talking phillips is probably
uh probably deserves to be on that list
as well kohl's
don't know about kohl's this is a
national broadcast oh yeah
yeah yeah so uh subway is great
[Laughter]
that cold cut combo let me tell you do
we have uh
what are we thinking for the live line
second half i'm trying to load them
right now
all right 602 we're being told though
602 is when the second half will work
out skeletor perfect time to grab a
drink uh spread the word
do i have a time do i have time to piss
sean am i allowed to do that
uh yeah but broadcast do i have to hit a
button or something
yeah i'm not i'm not able to to get
things loaded up so
all right there you go kramer what are
we looking at live numbers
that's what i'm trying to load up sean
oh okay work with me here i was i didn't
know if you were trying to load up the
sandwich
that was a do it yourself a favor it's
great just go to our
our instagram page it's bill belichick
just like
tearing sports gambling podcast on
instagram
hold on it's it's on the screen if
you're watching this you can see
the handle it's beautiful work by me
thank you
um but yeah we got uh
oh that's right we were showing the boss
rooting thing before that's great
whoa whoa here we go so i'm offended by
california
king sorry all right i'm gonna show this
shawn well while uh while we try to get
these lines loaded up
let's do it i hope i'm not hyping it up
too much but i think when you see the
photo it's it's amazing dude
it's pretty great i mean it's up on the
screen now and it must be uh
it must be if you can zoom in a little
bit kramer that would be awesome
it must be uh it must be some it must be
recent because you can see the
you can see the sound guy wearing the
mask wearing the covid welding mask
and just bill belichick just open mouth
it's almost like when a snake unhinges
his jaw but it's
instead of a mouse he's trying to muscle
down a jimmy john's foot long
dude gotta be honest any any sandwich
guys i'm a fan of you know what i mean
so
it's so hilarious he's the guy who's
like i don't do the you know like
refuses to do the media anything
you know related the media but now is
endorsing a sandwich i assume this is
from some commercial
maybe he's just taking lunch yeah that's
what i'm hoping no and they turned it
into a commercial
some guy just took a photo of him at
lunch
no no i mean like maybe he's on the side
of the set
that's what i'm thinking it is no but
look at they got the boom mic right
there
is that really the pants they would give
them yeah look at that boom the jim
harbaugh khakis
maybe it's a close-up on the black shirt
that would make sense black would make
him not look so
fat well and and uh i know i'm getting
old because those
those just white snakes with the tanky
that's a great look
they look comfortable loving those that
are like the ultimate dad's shoes
some feelers what are we wearing this is
every dad's your balance
just to sit on the park and just
deep throating jimmy john's hoagie
that's not a jimmy j i mean that's way
too there's too much like healthy
looking bread for that to be jimmy
john's yeah
we'll see so stay tuned the second half
number we have a minute the second half
number 49ers minus or plus a half minus
130 for the juice on that minus 110 on
the money line for the niners 23 is the
total
team totals 11 and a half for the
vikings niners
also 11 and a half interesting
anything pop off to you here sean before
we get this game started
plus a half and then what was the uh do
we have team total there we do 11 and a
half for both teams people upset that
i'm showing bill belichick sean
well i'll take it off the screen sir
wheel man
anything for you boss all right so uh uh
i'm gonna stand pant where i am i'm
gonna hope we get this back door we're
gonna need some finagling by mr kurt
should we get started let's do it 602
let's do it and so wait what was the
sorry what was the uh team total 11 and
a half and and it's under 24. if you
like the second half over sean it's 20
it's a 23.
yeah take the uh take the over second
half over 23. i'm feeling good about it
this feels like a good second let's go
the snow's mountain this is the time
this is when the vikings storm the beach
and start raping and pillaging let's go
oh man the snow is really melting at
this point except for the end zones
yeah there hasn't been much action there
let's do another 25
free play next touchdown scored come on
harry the hitman
let's go jimmy g out of the shotgun
hands off the most sir
jukes oh get to the outside goodbye
you're over
goodbye he's on the field
and harry the hitman kind of ducked him
there man r.i.p
the under and right now san francisco
with a
great career watch harry the hitman here
kind of kind of duck
the action oh he didn't want
any part of that tackle wow 49ers
already at midfield here
early in the third wow another hand off
to mostar
he is just a beast he's going to
crush me
yeah the under is dog right now
103.
we still have 15 yards cramer i mean we
just need some negative
yard carries no ipad still you would
think in the snow maybe you do
update it yeah first time for zimmer to
break out his eye patch
the white the reflection of the sun the
light off of the the snow
is not going to be good for those
accordion hands it off to moster
oh and he gets it man he gets popped
talking too i mean but we gotta see
the ball pop out it's
it's wet it's snowy it's cold
sean i i demand an investigation who was
on the sticks right now
no one kramer the court the computer is
playing itself
this is why we created computers third
and fourth jimmy g
out of the shotgun my cpu is a no-no
processor
[Music]
[Applause]
had to come back to get the ball and
just short of the
first go for it you gotta go if you're a
smart football coach you go for it here
it's plus 450 kramer gang half unit plus
450 on the budget they're going for it
love it onions play by the 49ers yeah
and they're in the shotgun
i love this get rid of it oh
god damn and that was
you're running it down their throats
with mostard and then why do you
run it on most importantly you're you're
playing good defense like just punt it
deep
and let your defense win this game now
you've given the vikings a ridiculous
sign they haven't been doing anything
for points i just told the kramer gang
to bet plus 450 it's down to plus
350. that's a big swing cousins under
center first and 10.
taking over at their own 41. and the
ball off back to throw
has time checks it down underneath
not much there that's fine who is that
osbourne again
that is uh that is osborne pretty sure
no
jefferson that's the guy who's the
rookie justin jefferson from lsu the guy
the eagles wish they had
nah he sucks seven's now that the live
spread sean it's it's drifting back
towards four and a half where we started
i still feel i i would wait to like play
goes under
seven and then take the 49ers hands off
to cook big hole at the middle in the
49ers territory it's been working
46. early on they were stuffing cook now
he's he seems to be getting eight yards
of clip
if you're a viking i want to see a
little play action now you got to work
the play action off of this
hit rudolph with that nice looping
crossing round
cousin's out of the shotgun first and 10
from the 46.
beautiful there you go there's a play
catch oh it's there for them all game
colby first down at the 35 colby rooting
aggressively against his
other bet you're so close i'll give up a
field goal we're okay
look we're up 13-3 kirk cousins hasn't
even i mean come on he's due for another
pick
fumble cousins under center first and 10
from the 35.
cook the lone back two tight end set
bubble screen
to thielen dylan's first catch of the
game
it's actually created as a rush
of course uh make sure you subscribe to
the sports game when podcasts
just uh went through a bunch of uh
player props
that we like for the quarterback
position for the 2020 nfl season
down to six and a half now sean is under
center second and eight
hands it off to cook nothing there this
is where the drive stops yeah they this
is where they go for like three yards
kick a field goal no screen right now
uh to you know like to eight or to eight
that's all right and and once again
third quarter under we tell you every
game
take the odd quarters under another slow
starting quarter we have zero points
six minutes in not acres by the way huge
third down here
third and six from the thirty one they
drop the screenplay
to get it to dalvin cook can he get the
first down sure ooh
couldn't get any better sherman shed the
blocker got the tackle
now forcing fourth in inches let's go
baby
one more catch great defense one more
catch by cook and i'm golden
not great start for the second half over
i'm not gonna lie
43-yard field goal from the right hash
it's up and it's good vikings make it a
one score game once again
a little nfl news jack prescott dakota
rain as we call him
did he finally come out no kramer uh
dakota rain prescott the final contract
no
offered by the cowboys is between 33 and
35 million annually disrespectful
with over 100 million guaranteed and
sounds like he might not take it that's
the same practical well it dalton's
better anyway right
well we may find out during the uh 2020
nfl season i saw him on the comeback
player of the year look at how good
those graphics are you can see the
the 49ers in the reflection of his
helmet that's
that's next how can they not figure out
franchise mode sean
yeah everyone el the madden the fanboys
are so pissed
that they can't figure out franchises
like what the hell are you doing
49ers will neil take over on their own
25 up seven here
8 30 left to go in the third you're
listening to the football tournament
presented by the sports gaming podcast
and my bookie daddy g
promo code tft and all things comedy
[Music]
yeah i mean would you rather have 100
million dollars in andy dalton
or dak cousins under center
person 10 from the 25. sorry jimmy g
kittle in motion
[Applause]
play action they pick up the pressure
completes it
ayuk ayuk
first stand down to the 43. colby jt
walton over on twitch wants to know how
many receptions does cook have
five we're we're almost there over under
his five and a half
we're almost there well i'm not on there
because colby
kobe st that was going to be my prop
colby steered me off of it
terrified me jimmy g under center first
and 10 from the 43.
i'm about to hit a trifecta here oh oh
lose the couple we're not dead yet john
not dead second and 12 from the 41.
we really could get uh if we could get
like a turnover maybe a touchdown take
the running game out of the equation for
the 49ers that would be great
come on now let's get something going
and uh to clarify his first name is
rayne
r-a-y-n-e his middle name is dakota
and his last name is prescott yeah and
his favorite band is
train oh how do you not make fun of that
guy
third and 12. he did go to mississippi
state oh okay
now we like mississippi state he's
probably the hail state is he the best
alumni
that come you know active right now
that's a good question montez sweat
[Applause]
with the shotgun third and 12 from the
41. bullet pass to the sideline
he is not a great passer of the football
look at those skinny arms
look at those you're going to back those
arms kirk cousins got
better arm talent than jimmy g
yeah he's afraid to show the uh doesn't
have any guns to show off man
they're hanging around they're hanging
around kramer
49ers should be up by more
oh no beautiful place down to the
two-yard line
okay this is bad this could be the game
right this could be a safety
kramer 50 free play if we see a safety
all right done
love it let's go save d come on boza
matt abercrombie saying madden obviously
doesn't have the shanahan playbook
downloaded yet
yeah uh sometimes they're play calling
the law i formation cousin's out of the
shotgun hands it off to cook
a little bit of room
that's perfect oh wait should i be
rooting for the safety you should
because
we're we're all about the fans i got
units on this bro
all right let's get aggressive second
and seven let's get some pressure split
up
a little bit i could use rudolph that i
love that whoever said that mickey rojo
let's go
hands off to cook once again nothing
there oh
actually he picked up three i mean these
look like three third and four
15 for 65 is not the worst day no
and you hear some chants of defense here
at levi's stadium in
beautiful san francisco california where
the snow continues the fall
perfect time to call a screenplay
cousins out of the shotgun third and
fourth
and they drop the screws baby and it
gets oh
he had him he had him
right there couldn't make the tackle cha
you know sean that reminds me of when
ahmad bradshaw
broke loose in the snow of buffalo to
run the giants into the playoffs and
route to defeating the
18-0 new england patriots
it's a baby wheel man cousins
out of the shotgun first and 10 from his
own 20.
back to throw checks it down underneath
that was a scary throw
he could fumble that's jefferson right
with the catch
yeah all right sean picks up eight
second and two six and a half
is the updated live number over at
mybookie.ag
use that promo code tft 34 is the total
i mean at some point isn't there gonna
be a barrage of scoring this is just
another
odd quarter under yeah first and third
quarter unders
play action get ready get rid of it get
rid of it
pressure lightning oh we got it first
down
oh my god smith jr with the catch but
that is
they're gonna challenge that right how
the hell did he get his feet in and he's
a guy
you know don't be surprised looks like
he got his toes can we do a little
little juggling action there don't be
surprised if you see him getting
involved
uh they have a very dynamic two tight
end opportunity
we got some skull chants firing away in
the twitch oh
oh oh what was that jet sweep to adam
thielen don't see that a lot if he
stayed
if he stayed on the outside he had he
had he had room it wasn't a bad play
call
he had it and just ran like a loser he
just
he had a hitch in his giddy up sean he
did much like bo
jackson second to nine
from the 38 cousins out of the shotgun
be horrible if you turn the ball over
here oh yeah that would be horrible
the late hand off the devil who loses
yards there we go
putting the vikings in third and 12. did
they let cousins throw this ball here
credit
third and two oh boy uh
you know i think colby might get another
catch well i'm already over so i mean
you you stopped caring about cook
catches yeah i'm done
cousins out of the shotgun third and
twelve from the thirty four
we like when he split out here all by
himself oh and
down he goes the fake draw play
didn't fool anyone cousins is sacked
and that's that i think i think we can
safely pencil in a third quarter under
sean
lock it up baby another odd under odd
quarter under
let's get some scoring going let's give
out a uh some more free play next
touchdown
we need harry the hitman to do something
vikings at the punt oh no this is still
a game though
oh wow oh oh oh oh
i think his foot was touching the ears
[Applause]
do we do another safety uh it's not as
fun when the 49ers yeah
i think we do another safety sean what
was the what was the terms
uh yeah there's a safety 50 free play
courtesy my bookie.ag
promo code tft craig z saying is this
madden seems so real
it is hey thank you jimmy g out of the i
formation
[Applause]
what a horrible play call oh what are we
how do you get that sean another photo
set up what do you want to do uh
yeah i don't know what do you want to do
let's do that all right send in a uh
send in a photo of your setup tweet it
out at gambling podcast
for a chance best one we'll pick is a
50 free play yeah bonus points if you if
you have a female in the picture
if you're watching with your girlfriend
what type of bonus points
like they might that might go to the top
of the pile you want 50
you want that 50 free play you know
maybe you could be one of the the few
female listeners
and they punt it into the wind they're
actually going to end up
that's all right that's pretty good it's
not bad for the 49ers
they're going to vikings will take over
at their own 33 down five and we're back
sean it's four and a half so 49ers still
covering that spread but by the
thinnest of margins and how do the odds
makers know how
do they know and now we have to sweat
this third quarter under we're at five
sean oh this is getting interesting
nine and a half i'm sure was the
pre-pregame uh number here
jimmy g or sorry cousins under center
hands it off to cook
almost breaks free and he's got 69 yards
shout out to everyone with 69 in the
username over in twitch
youtube how am i sweating wear that
badge proud wear that badge proud
no drone strikes needed tonight sean
that's promising
peace and love it's been a clean game
peace and love cousins under center
second and four clock
running here bubble screen oh oh oh
my god it was right in your hands how do
you not take that
he could have been gone that could have
been pick the rookie can't hang on to
that ball
that was no bueno sean
that was uh no bueno folded like a lawn
chair as they say
fifty dollar free play up for grab just
sending a uh sending a
photo of your setup sean we got a safety
how about that
cousin's back to throw and third and
four has to go and down here
he goes jesus ken law with the sack and
that's the rookie
yeah he could be good so look i got
right now i got samuel under five and a
half he's at two going into the fourth
you like that
colby is on fire ladies and gentlemen
that's what i'm saying man we're gonna
pick dundee's
back you come to the land on under
as they say player prop pick dundee
vikings get the punt off before the end
of the third
49ers will take over at their own 23
up five all right sean yes two to one
the vikings though
wow thirty-four is the total four
thirty-five points it's a one-score game
you're good
at a half is the spread and and again
third quarter under hits so here we go
can we get a surge who's sitting on an
over ticket
play action by jimmy g again bullet pass
completes it to iu
i thought it was 19. all right cool
harry the hitman is just not having a
game today
not locked in well you saw it when he
was when he dodged that
that uh that long run he didn't want to
make the tackle something's up
he's listening to us though he's going
to do something the spread's moved to
five
sean and it's 33 we're at 21. that's two
touchdowns
feels like there's going to be points in
the fourth quarter g
under center play action and god damn
pick it up pick it up
it goes to george kennel what a huge
break for the 49ers
instead of being a defensive touchdown
luckily just a six-yard loss that could
have been the game
oh that could have been a game-changing
play indeed we stopped doing play action
yeah
it's weird how killing us they've gotten
away from mostar completely which is
good
for my under most of rushing yards which
is but it's been bad for the 49ers
there they go mostly oh breaks it a
little bit
game of yard maybe hey he needs 11 yards
to get over
third and 15. no he's got we got 18 and
a half shot
we have 118 and a half mandarin tang
saying
how are you not uh doing espn for reals
well thank you mandarin
[Applause]
there's a petition that you could uh you
could go over to uh
get him get him get him damn it oh and
he almost gets another sack
danelle hunter is having himself a game
three so far
two on this drive that petition was on
change.org right
yes yeah so check it out go find it
someone has it in the chat
i'm sure they do big stop there by
minnesota forcing a punt
undergang is super relaxed we're gonna
have to sweat this though man
i thought we'd see a little scoring in
the second half but just nothing
oh yes no way
down at the one yard line are you
kidding me are you guys gonna back that
up again
with that play we're still accepting
entries
tweet out a photo of your setup at
gambling podcast i feel like we should
continue the safety gimmick
i mean safeties are so rare yeah let's
do it
and there's no way they're going to let
kirk cousins drop back to pass it has to
be a
a running play stuff it is and uh
cook picks up a handful making it second
and six no
sane person on the sticks would drop
kirk cousins back into his own end zone
with the snow he wouldn't know where the
line i mean he's still
close to safety zone though what are
they at the five
no now we're gonna have play action 95
yards to kyle rudolph
cousins out of the shotgun second and
six from his own five
back oh no get ready get rid of it as
time steps up
down the side oh you got it jefferson
wow keeps his feet in it's a hell of a
catch by justin jefferson
great pass protection by the o-line
oh my goodness nice catch great play all
around
oh what a catch by the great justin
jefferson again eagles would have been
blessed to have him instead
they get some scrub from tcu cousins
back to throw rolls to his right
checks it down to dalvin cook on the
move the vikings are starting to gain a
little momentum here sean
which is no longer exciting for uh
and we have enough time where they would
kick a field goal and just
kick the back door in jimmy g
maybe that's what he wants who knows man
is he playing the other side
maybe he just likes something getting
kicked in his back door
cousins out of the i formation hands it
off to down and cook nothing
there damn it we're gonna get another
punt situation niners are
with the win in the fourth quarter
minnesota has a small win to their face
we think
all right we got a 50 winner congrats to
abel
underscore 631. even got the photo with
his uh
got his supportive girlfriend in the
photo shout out to the supportive
girlfriend
here we go get there get there oh and
down he goes
you don't like that kirk do you i love
the play call bringing the safety blitz
when did it become cool to throw a fade
away up there yeah i don't know
they're just running these deep play
actions that uh of both teams
49ers and vikings and they're just
getting sacked
every single time
yeah they're going to have great field
position here
from the 20 out to near the 30.
i mean i got to imagine 30 yards there
in field goal range
field goal does not stretch it out past
one possession sean
no and helps with the back door though i
i i'm
i would love a field goal because yeah
it's still a one score game so they're
not gonna
not gonna leave the back door open
i generally like to close my back door
hands it off to moses
down he goes to the 39 right near that
rushing total at 114 yards
four and a half yards away are you
rooting against me right now
well second and one from the 39th son of
a
clock continues to run
uh g out of the i formation kittle in
motion it's time harry
it's time light up light that up
away delay a game whoa
is this is it is this game rig who's on
the stick i just made it all right the
story i just alluded that jimmy
g may be in on the fix but
jimmy g is definitely in on the fix
after that
what's he doing are you kidding me
let's go second and six from the 34. i
want a full investigation
all right investigations on going jimmy
g out of the i formation hands it off
to oh get there get there there we go
for the first day he is on the over now
you can still lose a yard and a
half though
oh god damn it how does he lose
he needs a fumble with under five
minutes to go where it goes backwards a
bunch and no one can advance it
all right so that's what we're rooting
for jimmy g out of the shotgun first and
ten from his own 40.
let's ice this game oh all right that
did he lose the yard i think he got it
yet god damn it
two yards god damn it
ah all right
[Music]
now we just need how are they so on the
spread this is just perfect though they
still haven't thrown to samuel
got seven minutes left you're golden
unless we go to overtime he needs four
catches
jimmy g out of the shotgun second and
eight from his 42.
loser do you hands it off the bar oh my
god it gets popped
he gained a yard on that you third
and seven
[Applause]
that was going on i didn't think he got
a yard
yeah shout out to monarch pride in the
chat uh who's giving the guy who
trademarked all the potential
replacement names uh in
in the virginia guy a hilarious move
dan snyder jimmy g
out of the shotgun completes it for a
first down
down to the 35 yard line
what's greatest is if it's someone
snyder knows and he just is forced to
keep the name redskins
no i mean it's changing right like
they've they've launched a full
investigation as they let people know
well now they're changing it to the dc
redskins according to the onion
the onion's still just crushing it jimmy
g out of the shotgun first and 10 from
the 35
hands it off to mostar nothing there
down he goes
he threw that who is 98
pierce he just chucked an offensive
lineman
tossed him like a rag doll that was
impressive that's the trench work i like
to observe
come on now is anyone relaxed right now
other than under betters
jimmy g under center second eleven from
36. hands it up to most
people and the hand comes through the
fight
there we go dude absolutely kill me
needed that anthony barr with the
recovery that's what i'm talking about
harry
calling in the drone strike mvp he's the
player of the game if they score here
cousins back to throw oh no oh yeah cook
gets loose on the screen
don't look now here come the vikings
hitman showing up when the team needs a
most
and shout out to the show biking sean oh
yeah it's all about it's all about the
vikings
not this football i like that show right
clock continues to run representation of
the vikings of the
the north cousins out of the shotgun
first and ten oh he's got too much time
way too much time deep ball oh and he
dropped on the
time holy toledo what is happening holy
toledo
is that who that is that is taj
wow jesus finally kurt coming through
with the help
this is how you attack the san francisco
49er defense over the top as they say
hand it off four times please four times
hannah high formation
[Music]
[Applause]
are they doing let's get a strip
sack there armstead what are you doing
for the spread though it's a field goal
it's just a dream scenario
and they will kick a field goal because
that does make it a one-possession game
you sure they would false start this
game joking it is a one-possession game
but yeah wow wow they got him on the
hard snap
second and five this is chaos from the
five
so how is it we jump on the we jump on
the sticks
or the mics and all of a sudden this is
why you bet on these things because even
though this has kind of been a shitty
game
it's still going to come down to these
last plays 27 is the live title i think
it's been a good game
second goal with the five cousins has
time
to find someone to the end zone yes
that'd be great if they declined it oh
rudolph a loser
there's gonna be an interception here
evan laganna saying didn't expect this
to be as crazy as it is
all these games are wild man i'm telling
you
i mean i'm certainly enjoying it
formation cousins under center
third and goal feels the pressure to the
end zone completes it for a touchdown
baby you like me you like that
dude this game's rigged it's rigged i
blame everything on the
delay game wow uh
now the vikings will go for two here
which could be huge
this could be huge this is especially
with the spread let's get this stop
cousins out of the shotgun run it to the
end zone
yes oh
if you took that to the house that would
have been two points for 49ers this is
crazy all right sean
you of course are watching the football
tournament presented by the sports game
when podcast my bookie daddy jeep promo
code tft and all things comedy sean you
got the uh kirk cousins drop give the
man a little respect
he he i mean as much as we like to make
fun of him that was a damn good ball
showing up in prime time
almost certainly locked up the cover
right um
well i mean 49ers could easily score a
touchdown here
they certainly need one and sean we're
calling the next game
yeah what do we got going on another
matchup in the divisional round
another one seed the baltimore ravens
hosting the tennessee titans
plus seven and a half for the tennessee
titans plus 225 on the money line 45 and
a half is the total
i'm liking this we saw the reverse of
this tennessee hosting baltimore last
week on the regular sims
it's gonna be a fun matchup he could
break it
and it might it's looking right now like
i'm gonna retain the pick sean i am
absolutely on a heater i'm gonna be back
to even
no way you jinx that camera no way
i'm feeling pretty confident nothing to
jinx
49ers take over first and ten from their
own 31 they have
three timeouts
jimmy g out of the shotgun first and ten
and sean did i mention i gave out a plus
450 money line
you did go oh juke move
you don't want to come inside when harry
the hitman's got his rifle
in the shooting position don't look now
49ers near midfield plenty of time to
score a touchdown and cover this thread
oh no
there's no touchdowns left sean there's
one there's no touchdowns left
for the san francisco 49. imagine
another touchdown uh
under better start getting nervous timmy
g
out of the shotgun first and ten ooh
completes
the monster he's still in bounds clock's
running
i'm telling you guys they're going to
get in field goal range and kick the
field goal if anything
if anything come on come on
what's what's more exciting a field goal
and then a minnesota attempt to come
back and win
a pick six who do we really want to see
advance here
pollock minnesota right we want the
vikings
completes it underneath the taylor oh
and he stays a two minute warrior
he's lucky he didn't break that tackle
are they in field goal range right now
sean
it's a 56-yarder with this snow with
this weather arguably the best kicker in
the game
your boy out of penn state and so far we
are redoing the 2019 nfl playoffs in
madden and so far
every team that won in the actual
playoffs has also won in the football
tournament
could we see an upset here for the first
time
jimmy g hands it off to mostert
oh no sorry that's uh coleman coleman
wow
well moster wants that trade so we're
seeing how coleman's gonna look in the
offense next year
picks up four second and six clock
continues to run 49ers have three
timeouts what is minnesota
when do they start calling timeouts i
don't know this is
this is certainly i would start
conserving some time i don't i don't
know why you're passing the ball right
now
he has time completely and he gets out
of bounds
that's huge oh no what are you what are
you rooting for i'm confused
a touchdown what are you confused about
is this
dwelly ross dwelling with the catch i'm
so diabolical over here
let's go 49ers here 22. great name ross
dewilly they're gonna hand it off
first and ten under jimmy g under center
benjamin in motion oh there was a bit of
a hole there couldn't take advantage of
it now the vikings use their first
timeout
second and five he got to i mean what he
just he's five yards on that play
and this is why 40 the 49ers can't just
run it a couple times to kick the field
goal they need to be aggressive
they need to get that touchdown and
force minnesota's hand wow
and sean you know you want to make sure
you head over to mybookie.ag
get get that account set up if you're
new because we're calling the late game
titans at ravens
[Applause]
jimmy g under center hands it off breaks
the deck
go and down to the eight yard line
timeout by minnesota
here we go this is it man this is first
and goal come on now
i don't know if i'm getting my money
kittle touchdown right now
don't know if i'm getting my money line
well
come on 49ers let's get a touchdown i
don't think you want to score a
touchdown i think your odds are better
if they kick the field goal what the
you talking about
i'm laying four and a half points
[Applause]
split eye jimmy g under center hands it
off to mostert nothing there
minnesota uses their last timeouts
mandarin wanting to know our bets closed
no
no plus 250 if you want to take the
vikings right now minus 500 on the
niners big spread there but
jesus you can head over to my bookie.g
at any time
yeah tft and bet the live line and and
we have
an entire slate of player props on the
tennessee
titans at baltimore ravens game so head
over to my bookie.he promo code tft
damn stop running it
okay now clock continues to run that's
it that's it
you're gonna keep the field going right
do they run it well
they gotta throw us a slant right here
what was the final score of this game in
real life the the niners were really
destroyed
yeah good job good job by the vikings
out of the gun don't run it oh no
third and goal yeah
[Applause]
they're gonna go for two right oh
you under bettors just got real tight it
doesn't matter
what do you mean overtime baby you don't
you want your right
but it doesn't matter for my four and a
half oh here we go framer you know how
to jinx a bet
49ers for the two-point conversion jimmy
g x
pick two pick two fumble pick two
[Applause]
oh interesting garbage man
now what will they kick the field goal
to cut it to two
yeah yeah
yeah they might oh my god late cover and
now
all the pressure will be on kirk cousins
is that vikings will take over down five
in san francisco
i'm i'm 51 seconds away from going three
for three on the bench oh
dee is feeling good mush you could cut
the tension with a knife
i could tell you that uh what's his name
he's not getting that was a hell of an
answer by the 49ers
great drive doesn't does cousins have
magic left in the tank
are we about to see a sand for the
miracle in levi
what do we need to see first play it's
got to be like a they have to get like a
40 yard play right
well the problem is no timeouts and they
the these madden teams are real
shitty with the hurry up offense okay
good start they're not wasting caught
can they if they get a 30-yard play to
start they have a shot they're in
as long as they're in hail mary range
they have a shot
the problem is the pass rush i i think
this game probably ends with a fumble
i think uh you get one sack and that
really is huge because it takes him so
long to set up
clock continues to run look for uh
really any stop inbounds is gonna be
tough
look for nick bosa to make a play here
cousins out of the shotgun first and ten
from their own
twenty five they get through the
pressure
bounces off the hands of rudolph can't
pull it down nearly intercepted nearly
sacked
second and ten okay well
hell of a first game yeah and this is
why you watch the sims
this is why you listen that's why they
play the games
come on now dee make a stop cousin's out
of the shower
no checks it down he gets out of bounds
oh
that's actually not so bad that's all
right and that's high level time
management for these sims
kj osborne the rookie getting getting
some burn i got trapped i'm not trapped
i'm not trapped yet as long as my man
kurt has a breath left in his body
and there's a second left in this game
we got a shot
do you believe in miracles cousins out
of the shotgun they bring pressure
and he gets it off they break to death
oh my gosh and
it should remind people kirk cousins
does have a hail mary uh on his on his
at michigan state yeah against russell
wilson he also
uh accidentally kneeled the ball and set
a spike in it at the end of the uh first
half of an eagles game
counting on that counting on that man so
he's got a lot of range
real quick they just moved like 30 25
yards in a couple seconds and
36 seconds on the clock they should be
able to get a ball to the end zone from
here armstead breaks through
and down he goes that's the cousins i
like how he slapped the ball
got to take the ref an extra few seconds
to get the ball that's it
idiot you were doing so well you
just gotta throw it away
this is the last play kirk last place
will they get a playoffs they do or
looks like they should
last play from the 40
games on the line kirk cousins checks it
down to dalvin cook
love it love it that'll do it for the
game
three for three baby welcome to the land
down under
oh i lost my units go eat a vegemite
sandwich
kramer mml tour container now done down
four units
it was a forest fire last week this week
it's the goddamn
vikings they had it such a vikings loss
such a vikings way to lose a game
defense is great all game
they let them drive down the field in
like 10 seconds brutal
what a uh what a fun game and uh and so
we're not going anywhere no we're not
we're gonna we're gonna wrap up this
game and then
get started with the late game as we
continue to uh
move things along here on the football
tournament presented by the sports
gameplay podcast and my bookie.ag
wow what a uh man what a game kramer of
course doing everything he can
to jinx the bet and he does
that was a great game though man oh that
was great i mean
19 to 14 in the snow in san francisco
what more do you want
football baby football
it was a good run it's a good run it's
back to four it's your pick now sean
you are down four units well let's recap
this game first
let's do it let's go through some of the
player props
i mean really at the end of the day the
story of the game was right here third
down conversions and the fact that
goddamn harry the hitman could he
couldn't get it done he couldn't get
that big he had got one big play
changed the game they score the
touchdown and then the defense just
falls apart
joey mega millions says dundee you get
this next pick and i'll get you a hand
job
wow oh wow do they have those at porto's
as well hello
yeah they do they do have great
customers tender love and care
but of course no restaurant is better
than the brat stop in beautiful kenosha
wisconsin shout out to broadstop the
best
place for bratz in wisconsin or north
america jimmy g goes over his passing
total
and his passing touchdowns total his
completions total
just short i think it opened at 22 and a
half not yet
uh 32 and a half was the attempts again
came in just
over that was the opener let's see what
else we have here
orange and blue all day yes we are on
for the next game too so stick around
kirk cousins went over the yardage did
not go over the passing touchdowns of
one and a half
completions over 23. wow goddamn these
oddsmakers are good
came just under the opener of 23 and
pass
attempts goes right over wow all that
every quarter same similar situation
just over there
the numbers on point for this game let's
head over to the rushing stats
most ah most are he killed wow he really
did
he went he he he went for it and he
crushed us
dalvin cook on the other hand looked
like he was gonna get some done did
not go over his rushing yards that's
it's pretty shocking
uh moving over to the receiving cook
just a monster game
wow i got scared off by pick dundee
taking over five and a half
receptions if it was dantebase maybe but
you should
went over the receiving yards in one
play
uh meanwhile i didn't even call his name
but tevin coleman under 18
and a half rushing yards we should have
been all over that he does not
get much look here and then uh do we
have any mostar receiving no but we do
have let's see kyle rudolph went under
both
unfortunately that's another loss for
the kramer gang adam thielen
he went under both ways he didn't do it
one catch five yards
no it sounds like a type of
performance he's being a total
total hand job george kittle george
kittle not a great game he went under
with both
yeah receptions in total they stopped
throwing to the tight end debo
samuel went under both recipients
total and brandon ayuk well
sean he also did he he might have come
closer
let's see he goes over for his
receptions he was at four and a half and
he goes over for yards with 62 and a
half so the one the loan over
sean was brandon iu wow that's crazy
i i didn't expect to see that
but man the streak continues of running
back to 2019 nfl playoffs
every team that won the actual playoffs
have won in the football tournament
are we gonna see something new are we
gonna see history being rewritten when
the
baltimore ravens host the tennessee
titans kicking off
in 15 minutes colby's going
we've blocked colby 19. i'm gonna i'll
leave this up for a little bit
make sure everyone's got everything but
yeah
1914 a very unconventional score here
yeah i mean it was a weird game we
almost saw a second safety
did the vikings win the second half
the niners were plus a half in the
second so yes the vikings won
the second half under second half
1914 wow not not something you see every
day but there you go and now sean
the san francisco 49ers will be one half
of the nfc
championship game set to be played
saturday july 25th
championship saturday the opening game 3
p.m on the west coast
6 p.m on the east coast that's going to
be the opening game of a triple header
sean a
triple a football triple header you
don't see that every day
no you don't you only see it in the
football
tournament and it's
it's weird how chalky this has been
it is it's it's it's not been chalky
though both six seeds advance just like
in real life we just happen to be
mimicking real life right now
agreed kramer let's uh i'm gonna slide
over to
titan's ravens get get that preview
going
well i'm gonna i'm gonna wait for the uh
i'm gonna wait for my bookie to let us
know they're good
on grading all the player props got all
yeah that's important stats on the
screen make sure everything's good uh
but yeah and people were asking earlier
i noticed over in the chat
where where can they find or when when
can they see
the other divisional match-ups of course
the houston texans and the kansas city
chiefs
one half of that and then seattle at
green bay
they're going to be playing the day
before championship saturday friday july
24th 8 p.m on the east coast 5 pm on the
west coast that's going to be houston at
kansas city where kansas city is minus 7
sean wow and then the nightcap at 10 pm
on the east coast 7 p.m on the west
coast
seattle heads to green bay as you said
a lot like real life and that number is
packers minus four and a half
minus 240 on the money line seahawks
plus 165.
you might want to listen to the latest
episode of the sports gambling podcast
or i guess it's going to be dropping
shortly yes where we talk about some
props where i may like
a certain a certain quarterback on the
seattle seahawks
whose name rhymes with muscle
all right sean yes kramer
[Music]
you can get all the information on the
payouts brian ross
just go to sportsgamerypodcast.comatc
that's got you covered i'm already i'm
already looking ahead to this late game
checking out some of these player props
lamar jackson rushing yards
91 and a half tana hill passing yards
268 and a half
tan hill throwing touchdowns over one
and a half but there's a bunch of juice
on that
uh what do i do here i feel like i got
job pretty hard last time on these
titans props
but i will be kramer i'm going to make
my announcement right now
i'm going to take the titans plus
announcements
titans do i have to show the sliders
again i forget the protocol
sure jesus christ i'm going to be taking
titans plus seven grammar
you know what's going on ravens minus
seven sean you know i like to team up
with other
great name great people named ryan
you're gonna you're gonna steal you
you're gonna steal that from me you're
gonna steal that opportunity
oh hell yeah so i guess i'm gonna have
to go with lamar vic
in the baltimore ravens show although
they they've looked better but seven
seven points is just way too much i feel
like that we we have regression due
i'm feeling good about the pick i got to
get back we're at four units now
uh what are some of these other
interesting ones mark andrews
54 and a half receiving yards over four
catches oh we
thank you for calling no we haven't we
haven't hit that yet and that's gonna be
one of my props
i'm with you man snead is an absolute
favorite target of lamar jackson what's
the number at it's now moved to four and
a half
ooh that's fine i still like it over
let's go we're
hold on i'm gonna go grab our uh gr grab
our media guides for the next game
there you go nice nice colby dan aka
pick dundee what are you uh what are you
leaning on this late game
i'm back in the titans it's too many
points we've seen this raven team
you know really disappoint in this game
even though lamar jackson the the new
update my the
cpu is you know that processor or
learning computer because he's gotten a
lot better the cpu is enrolling that
processor
um so so that's that's encouraging if
you're a ravensbacker but i still think
seven points too much
give me the titans yeah yeah no that's
crazy
yeah i i seven points i mean the raven
team has looked better but
still seven points is a lot madden and
we see these
these late comebacks where things get
get interesting
i mean tani hill is is my you know i
like to say tanny hill
um oh i know he's uh he's a little bit
of a wild card that's the only scary
part about backing the tight the titans
he can get real hot and cold
and i like i like the titans but i think
i would almost go
i'm not gonna make this an official play
but if i had to i would probably go
under on his passing yards it's a 268
and a half yeah gun to my head i'm
taking i'm taking the other there
yeah 268 and a half why yeah you know
what
i'm going to do it tana hill under 268
and a half passing yards that makes
sense
but hollywood brown over three didn't
didn't he have a decent game last game
he did yeah well now it's three and a
half
so again colby people are hearing your
picks they're moving numbers left and
right
hey dundee dundee does one thing down
under he wins all right
so uh okay now uh let me look at some of
these other ones here
cause cory corey dave has been a really
hot receiver recently you're right he
has
but i almost feel like maybe you fade
him now you know what i'm off that
i'm gonna retract my tana hell pick
because i no i'm just remembering now
that corey davis
he really got hot yeah but but can that
be consistent
we'll see
i mean 78 and a half for the receiving
yards for corey davis six receptions
if i mean i guess i'm staying away from
that
i'm not going to bet that but i think if
i had to
brad winslow's saying tanner hill is a
bum at least he got into miami and
into a team with the structure i i think
at least he got that smoking hot
white is he a bum what do we know if
he's i think i think it's clear that
adam gase is the bum
and tana hill maybe not amazing but
certainly probably not as bad as he
looked in miami and
probably not as good as he looked last
year he's probably in between all right
he still sucks i think
colby big decisions here what are we
doing for outfits
um dare you let me go all purple
let's do it ah the gold is so horrible
though
it should be a white number all right
i'll i'll entertain what else we got
here
that's that's a good idea all blacks
that's a good idea i'm i'm leaning all
black right now
i'll let the chat over there's really
only like two teams that can do purple
successfully that's
east carolina and tcu oh okay
like vikings is trash purple we're we're
going all black
yeah let's deal with it let's do it just
a little bit of purple's not that bad
but if you're going to go like all
purple that golden those gold numbers i
passed the all blacks
yeah well you did you did all right
all right sean's not here so we can do
whatever we want well you know what we
want
last time we did titans that no no
i we still have to do that every time
now no i'm just
i'm i'm personally making it a choice to
not
i don't want to do throwbacks i don't
want to offend you we did these horrible
you know
they have horrible uniforms let's see
what else let's see what we got for
options
that's pretty fire that shout out to
alex crouch 93
my bad i did forget kansas state also
does it really well
kansas state you're right alex you are a
hundred percent right
you let me know when you see something
that's fire to you corbin
man it's tough you know what i think the
titans are just a teal
horrible uniform hill's a tough color
everything about them the titans the
symbol teal is a tough
color i'll i'll give you that it's it's
just not
there's nothing scary about it why why
do they have so many uniforms they don't
have too much going on the shoulder
pad's a different color
like that that's the thing maybe i'm
maybe i'm just that's fine
are we doing this yeah yeah anyone
opposing that helmet is as good as it
gets man that helmet is fly
oh that's a classic too i could do that
all day i think i'm gonna do that all
day i think we're gonna do this though
we're gonna
we're gonna do this we're gonna go all
white
that's beautiful that looks absolutely
beautiful sorry
oh brazen gator fans saying no oilers
he's saying no last time we did titans
do we what if we throw a titan's oh no
what did i do i lost my custom it's just
great
okay so if we go here and then we just
change the
let's let's let's go to the the titan's
helmet no we need a white we need a
white
there we go how's that how's that
brazing it's a shitty helmet but i mean
just give them it
just give them it no you know what
i like brazing gator fan not like you
colby
i like the guy i'm wanting bets over
here buddy i like the guy so i'm gonna
say
i'm gonna suggest we do this but we
gotta go with a white helmet
oh that's flawless right right here
jesus this is what we're doing
kramer's making the call everyone else
sit the down
i mean there's a reason why they look
like an xfl uniform right
brazen gator fan i'm on your team bro
all right it looks like we're good to
start at seven o'clock
let's do it sean have i given out a prop
yet no
what are you doing prop wise well i i i
think colby
uh unfortunately i'm a little worried
now that he's going to definitely mush
this but
why would you be worried when i'm 3-0 if
the previous game because cause you're
due willie steed over four and a half i
mean we've seen the way that lamar
really likes to throw it his direction
um
running backs generally like we like the
under right i don't think i'm gonna go
near that
but if there's a i
i was looking at jono smith that's a
pretty big number now
there's not a ton of stuff i like here
so i'm gonna stick
i'm gonna stick with the the single
snead over four and a half and i think
i think i want to go lamar jackson
over 91 and a half right wow i'm gonna
i'm gonna go with the chalky play but
it's gonna be a fun one
lamar vic over 91 and a half i got one
for you to hop on
yeah what's that look we're already on
sneed i say it double down let's go
with hollywood brown over three catches
it's three and a half but i'll three and
a half yeah let's take a good game
i'll take over hollywood brown three and
a half catches and the more i think
about it the more
i'm buying into ryan tanny hill as colby
says give me the over in passing yards
268 and a half
let's go all right i'm gonna so
you're saying you're taking hollywood
brown over the catches or the receptions
because i
i kind of want to go reset receive
what's the yards there 36 and a half
actually no that's even better that's
that's not one yeah not three and a half
hours
let me let me actually let me go over
here and do this that's one catch for
hollywood
no that's that's gonna happen and then
of course as we always recommend
first and third quarter unders are we
co-signing they're nine and a half both
ways are we saying
sure toss that in
all right are people ready i'm ready
three minutes still kick off
just got getting it shout out to kennel
to kennel killer
thousand on under under 91 what's he
talking about under nine maybe
exclamation point
ninety oh 91 yards oh he's got the other
side of the rushing
bro why are you bringing that negative
energy into the chat
you know the kramer gang's all about
positivity peace and love
shout out to dick gerthsberger over on
youtube legend
long
shout out to mj with a lot of 12s asking
if there's
thousand dollar limits on player props i
mean it depends what kind of baller you
are but
i believe they've gone as high as twenty
five hundred percent hashtag
select clients like concept and others
who hang out in the
just tons of room for social distancing
vip
room brought to you by cushy dreams
oh the premier leader when it comes to
smokeable cbd go to cushydreams.com
promo code sgp
15 off your c b
d and uh quick update ace blazer
informing us that
concept one of our og uh vips has been
banned who knows i wonder what he was up
to
maybe uh an epstein island photo
surfaced
two too many nosebears he was
photographed with the
gillian maxwell the dude would come into
the chat every night
yo what's up five dollar gang
i love the psychology of that guy he's
the same guy that thinks it looks cool
to carry a purse
shout out to vegas dave the you
gonna carry up
i don't care if it says lv on it
whatever brand wheel you're
gonna carry a purse
this is the vegas dave took the chargers
sidebar
we have a minute real quick it's the
same people that are getting into fanny
packs
like all right we're calling them
they're really we're probably getting
into that
are people getting into fanny packs they
don't call them fanny packs but people
are into fanny packs
kramer like it what makes his pop
culture radar or
trend radar is very bizarre
remember no one's getting into panty
packs you just probably did this
neighborhood or something we probably
saw
two dudes with the panty packs and was
like i got names all right
people are getting into fanny packs i'm
telling you no the only
uh professional wrestlers love fanny
packs i don't know what that is i've
never got that explained to me
i haven't been watching much
professional wrestling so they're the
only ones when they're not
when they're not wrestling they're uh
all right who we we
they're seven o'clock sean are you ready
let's chat we haven't done this in a
while but throw some emojis out there
let's get this started fire away sean i
have two units
yes on ravens minus seven you do
i have one unit on snead over four and a
half catches yes
one unit on hollywood brown over 36 and
a half
receiving yards i have lamar jackson
over 91 and a half rushing yards for a
unit
and to sum it up and then i have a unit
on under first quarter and under
third quarter nine and a half points
each so i'm on over
tannehill uh passing yards first third
quarter under
check uh check hollywood brown receiving
yards
and uh snead catches i'm co-signing this
we're on a lot of things
we agree on a lot this can never go well
sean well and a lot of people are
calling for the live
dog and uh shayno's saying
lamar passing touchdowns over one and a
half plus 140 actually
i like that feels low yeah i'm a little
worried i
i don't know if i'm going to invest in
that though i didn't take that look i
just
stayed with the ravens white outs took
the over 32 yards or 34 yards whatever
that was
and uh and also let's get this can we
should we do a little cheers real quick
cheers
you of course are listening and watching
the football tournament presented by
sports gambling podcast
myboogie.ag from code tft and
all things comedy let's go baby let's
kick it off
oh oh my god i've done i've outdone
myself again
ryan these uniforms are oh
so fire filled with drip look at the
formation
henry the deep back shout out to magic
man
tannehill under center
[Applause]
hands it off to henry picks up a couple
all white's looking pretty fresh
shout out to dick gerthsberger says i
introduced a senior living facility to
your channel
oh wow shout out yes they turned down
the sound he said
but i mean that's still that's great all
right well i was gonna shout him out but
now they don't get a shout out
look they wouldn't be able to hear even
if they had the sound so you know
dana hell under center second and seven
from their own 28.
[Applause]
oh oh adam humphreys jet sweep don't
want to do that don't bring that weak
ass stop
back-to-back games where we've seen them
try to use a white receiver as a running
back
it's not gonna work now we this is where
the rubber meets the road when it comes
to earl thomas's off-season program
can he separate another man from the
ball
that kind of worked tannehill out of the
shotgun third and nine from the 26th oh
taking a shot sideline oh he going to
several oh thomas
that hit the ground how about them
[Music]
[Applause]
though that's how i'm gonna spin it spin
spin spin lori uh
anogee saying how about a cheers and a
kiss on the lips
whoa sorry sorry loriann og in the
youtube htc i'm taking
the only single one available no no no
oh no colby picked undies and love
i mean my on camera personality isn't
married there you go
blow the bot a kiss kramer oh no i don't
blow kisses
mark ingram with the carry there
bringing up third and two from the 46.
you never know who might catch it sean
especially in these cobit times you
don't want to
hawaii sorry hawaiian built to say is
there a way to see the current bracket
just go to
swordsgamingpodcast.com atc it'll be
updated uh
you know tomorrow for these games
ingram barely gets it get there
like a guy just specifically going out
of bounds looks like he was running to
the bathroom
oh not a good start for you sean
not a good start i got titans plus seven
what's bad about that not a great start
for you
shout out to the kramer gang dan hill's
getting aggressive i love it
shout out to the state of maryland lamar
under center high formation
play action past time checks it down
oh yeah baby there we go
[Applause]
a mac player dominating is troy palamalo
your favorite player
to have gone to usc no
but yeah i do like palomala there's a
sail guy not a lot of
not a lot of guys i like out of ufc
jackson under center reggie bush
high on that list
hands it off to ingram again i've always
been a todd maranovich fan okay
that's my guy if you live in the los
angeles area and you're not listening to
petros you're missing out bro
no i know sean we're not allowed to
throw shout outs to competitors and
everything
which is why we're gonna tell you you
should subscribe to the sports gambling
podcast
lamar jackson under center i formation
second and seven from the 32
tight end in motion
[Applause]
ends it off to ingram once again they're
right there close the shoulder
that offensive line is getting a push
showing that's what they come from
one getting a push they are the big
uglies up front
moving the line
it's a great shot of the head coach mike
grebel who said he would be willing to
cut his dick off to win a super bowl
same could be said for the football
tournament championship game
we'll see
[Applause]
and this was the ravens problem and sims
passed a lot of field goals not a lot of
touchdowns
people asking magic man asking when when
can you hear about the oregon ducks
even with the schedule in flux things
swirling around
uncertainty everywhere yeah colby dan
and
patty c are continuing to break down
every power five team
44-yard field goal from the left hash
it's up
you should head over to where great
podcasts are found and search for the
colleagues experience and you'll see a
shitload of team previews already on the
feed i think we're up into the m's
yeah the middle m's michigan maybe just
launched maybe michigan state
and and uh oregon will not go 8 and 4
this year because they're not playing 12
games
well they might pick up some extra
conference games that's yet to be
figured out right
hawaiian built checking in saying these
guys are great good luck
everyone oh thanks for the good luck and
even throws in the little uh mahalo
or what do you call this the hang loose
that's that's right in line with my
peace and love
love the great state of hawaii get a
shaved ice poke bowl
shout out to june jones hell of a good
guy you know to this day sean when you
call me on the rare chance you call me i
get the the picture of you at that shave
ice place
hawaii the one with obama yeah awesome
ravens out to a three-nothing lead here
wow there's some windshields we have
some wind and maybe that was why
tannehill was
a little short with that throw
down the field what are we looking at uh
live line crammer people just tuned in
wanted to bet it
well the first hannah hill i like this
grabbing guys by the shoulder pads
you gotta love it henry lone back right
now under center synonymous with leader
let's get things going here first and
ten
at the 25. nothing there for derek henry
and we've seen this before if they
fail to get henry going it's generally
not a great thing
and and it's going to have to be ryan
taylor or ryan tannehill
syncing up with those i mean they they
have the receiving talent
just not the quarterback town we don't
know and the raven the live number over
at mybookie.hg sean the ravens are minus
seven
we're right where we started
tana hill play action has time second
and ten
oh nearly throws another interception so
lucky
i mean i guess that makes up for the
first one because the first one was
pretty ridiculous
yeah yeah definitely plus 250 for the
titans if you like them not much
changing though 43 is still the total
that's dipping down a little bit from
the opener at 45 and a half
third and 10 from the 25 tan hell out of
the shotgun
guys get something here where's adam
humphries
don't run it play action oh my god this
titan's offense looks horrible dude like
barely
i mean potentially sax saving block by
derek henry
imagine caleus campbell running down at
you like that and then
leaping up in the air with the vertical
to casually slam dunk a basketball
not a good spot to be in if you're ryan
tannehill
fourth and ten titans are gonna punt but
they're only down three sean
and remember this is the problem with
the goddamn ravens team
yeah they just keep settling for field
goals and when you're catching seven
points like i recommended
uh you can be put in a decent position
and now they get the ball back to maybe
snead and hollywood brown can get get
things going
hollywood hollywood oh he's up to no
good
didn't that coach look like a ghost go
back to that show that again
and this is that uh swinging gate type
formation
lamar out of the shotgun hands it off to
ingram not much there
he should have kept it for the he read
that wrong he had a lot of space if he
if he goes if he goes selfish there and
holds that ball he's gone maybe
brad winslow's saying tana hell equals
bum i thought we covered this already
that is true yeah well he had some
moments
you agree how are you so lenient on
tanny hill and like
i find your you're judging of
quarterbacks
oh here we go well i i thought i thought
tana hill had a dc year last year but
who am i who am i harsh on but
i mean there's some that i don't know i
mean just saying like going through i
don't know i mean tanny hill and sam
bradford is there a big difference
uh well more of an athlete tayden hill
got him to a native championship game
and we don't know
i mean sanchez did that no no but i mean
really anything
yeah no i mean i watched the games like
tannehill had a really good deep ball
he had some moments this year i mean
yeah
before this year i think it would be
fair
[Applause]
pushes off there but they don't catch mr
hollywood brown with the deep ball catch
i think it's impossible to debate ryan
tannehill because i think it's fair to
throw out what happened in miami
he's in a better system now he's got
receivers very good last year it was
really the run game
very mark sanchez i thought like i
thought oh i don't remember sanchez ever
i mean
he went into kansas city was throwing
the ball well i mean
that i mean if you remember that ravens
game i mean the ravens are like one of
the better teams in the afc
and they get the ball and he just throws
that 40-yard dart into the end zone
he's very like he he's totally the
the j.r smith irrational confidence like
he's too dumb to realize the moment
and now that he's in a system like his
talent might actually be able to shine
lamar out of the shotgun completes it
against the hollywood brown
so if you did if you took the catch
thing you got two wait is that him
i thought oh no sorry that's uh duvernay
i thought that was 15.
but i think it's also okay to feel like
tana hill's a bum
and he was benefited greatly by a great
running game and a good defense
but we'll get to see that's the beauty
of it we'll get to see this fall
i i think he looked okay last year look
i got nothing against the guy
i would say before this year definitely
get in lamar walks into the end zone
[Music]
ravens this this is not looking
good for you they scored a touchdown
sean nope first quarter
is burned
[Applause]
[Music]
now because scary thought is now that
now we're almost going to be forced to
throw
he's got over 12 and a half for the
raymond's team total that that's got to
feel good
everyone else what do you got who's got
what who's relaxed right now over
betters or over bettors feeling a little
relaxed
it dipped down to 43. it's certainly not
going to be at 43 when it reopens
coming out of this score four wow really
eric carter i got a hit refresh just to
make sure snead has one catch so far
yeah it's one catch yeah they've really
only had like a
they've had a quick couple positions
hollywood brown had that 50 yarder
that was that's fine because that cashed
us a ticket
you're welcome for talking you off of
the receptions
yeah that's true even though i don't
feel like that's a horrible bet either
no three no but i mean the the fact that
you get a speedster who can catch it in
one
in one nugget that wasn't easy money
easy money buddy
and you'll see sneed is the favorite
target of lamar jackson
but the concern is they might not need
to pass you're going to see a heavy dose
of marking
um and lamar running a bit titans will
kneel it
looks like they're still going into that
wind not crazy
because the kickoff didn't go out of the
end zone but certainly a little bit of a
factor
tennessee been able to do nothing so far
on the offensive side really need to get
just get a little rhythm going get a
couple points field goal's fine just
something
and the live number over at mybookie.ed
promo code tft
11 and a half for the ravens 47's the
total titans plus 300
tannehill out of the empty set first and
ten checks it down
nothing there that's good if you have
the jonus smith over receptions casino
he's a he is a favorite target of ryan
tannen
needs to get corey davis going
clay's campbell there got in there on
the tackle tannehill one for four for an
interception so
very bum-like performance so far i
like i hope he succeeds for his sake but
i'm just saying like i have never been
wowed by him oh no i mean
i thought he was a bum before this year
but he certainly looked better this year
58 just got undressed
that was a hell of a joke wow aj brown
aj
brown i mean this guy could be uh he
could be good next year i mean he was
already pretty good
he went to ole miss where you know uh
their coach was at the strip clubs down
in tampa all the time and i'm sure he
got a bag of cash
here we go tandy hill high formation
third and two from their own 33.
corey davis in motion up top give it to
derrick henry
got a block a it's simply a
numbers game
simply a numbers game that's a great
drop
simply another number but dude they're
sending more than the
the like the protection well again
you're seeing quality coaching versus
maybe not so quality coaching
period this is tough we're gonna need to
pick six
we're gonna need some turnovers i mean
we're just the play calling sucks
and yeah brad winslow pointing out this
is the worst case scenario for the
titans offense playing from behind
keeps henry out of the game although
he's he's a weird
factor in this game to begin with and
sean if you're not watching on the
sports gambling podcast twitch page you
should make sure to head over there hit
the follow button because
last week you would have gotten to
participate in the fantasy football
draft
we do over there he's going to do some
some tecmo super bowl
hell yeah lamar jackson hands it off to
sneed
jet sweep damn it i don't like seeing
that
that's all right that doesn't help
anything you get injured or something
you know just not necessarily oh you're
worried about the injury i like that
concerned about the player's health
colby down pick dundee
man of the people
all right second and three out of the
pistol
lamar jackson from his own 24. they're
just not
guarding sneed hands it off to ingram
gets to the outside
first down turns it up field this game
could get ugly out of bounds at the 39.
it could get ugly this could be the
first if it's a touchdown
we could be uh deviating from the path
sean could be the first difference from
the real
the real two thousand thousand baltimore
ravens actually win a playoff game
under lamar jackson we could be seeing
that here
first and ten from his own thirty-nine
left a lot of game hands it off to
ingram
nice tackle there by the titans
got to get a stop here kennel killer
saying he's
he's taking a big fat rip off waterbong
and enjoying his winnings what's the
last time you guys did
it's been a while for me to find i mean
any sort of
water pipe yeah i don't know like a
couple weeks
that's second to none out of the shotgun
checks it down hollywood hollywood so
harley grading that as a catcher i think
it is yeah
i mean listen for 60. there you go hope
you listen to my
pick even though i changed it can i tell
you can i uh divulge something
ben been uh hanging out on the roof a
little bit from time to time
you get up on my roof you get a nice
view of uh you know the lights of the
city
going up there with the pipe okay i like
it lamar
third down play action looks to roll
yeah oh what slides well short of the
first step
louisville i gotta be honest i got
gifted like a big jar of weed from a
friend
so you know just it's cool dude you
don't have to pretend like you didn't
dude i don't buy things all right i
don't buy i don't buy
i don't buy alcohol and drugs man i got
i got a dealer i got an alcohol
do you have an alcohol dealer i don't
know it's a liquor store called me
no no no i gotta i got a i got a guy
that drives by who's
he's just a hobo no no actually you know
him
but i can't i can't i can't plug him i
can't plug him this is like the uh the
guy that walks down the beach oh big
stick
popsicles i'll put it like this like his
his
wife works for a bunch of companies and
i think maybe he does alcohol companies
so he always says dude you you need to
re-up and i'm like sure and he puts like
five or six liquor bottles in a bag
drives by my house sounds legit
and i never know what it is patty c
thought it was crazy because he's like
what are you getting rum
or you know whiskey and i go i don't
know man it's just five random alcohol
if it's bubble screen corey davis
john says
[Applause]
kyle uh zajac checking in on the atc
youtube
what does it mean total over 12 minus
second quarter titans updated rosters
versus second quarter ravens updated
rosters
that of course is the combined score of
the second quarter
over under check it down to derek henry
henry needs a run over dudes what's
going on keep checking it
i mean luckily it's only 10 nothing so i
guess we can but
i don't know yeah it looks like that
looks like kyle bet the over
he over for the second quarter which you
know second and fourth quarters are
generally good scoring quarters right
now we're
we're sitting at zero just the beginning
of it titans have yet to get a first
down can they get one here they go
break that breakdown oh wow earl thomas
earl thomas
coming in with the cleanup on aisle 11.
he was uh didn't even his brother's help
for that one
he was coming in there to close as if it
was a an
h that needed an extra leg to it i think
their finishing move is to cross
streams and then ask for prayers
tannehill out of the shotgun trips to
the bottom empty set
back to throw here you go corey davis
getting him involved let's go baby oh
they're like the brothers in the
boondock saints they're putting the
coins on the chick's eyes
before they just pull out these massive
dongs and
the rest is history we're of course
referring to the story about earl thomas
and his
brother uh sharing a woman's company
getting busted by earl thomas's wife
and then putting out a statement uh
asking for people to pray for them in
their time of need
just pray for us as we go through this
derek henry with the first down and this
titans team on the move
uh offense heating up let's go baby i
mean generally when sean's feeling down
i pick him up and
we go to a hotel room and just remove
our clothes and just
watch each other chicks yeah well i
did pray for him it's great
corey davis now didn't i say that i said
get gory davis going
i forgot if i threw him in my player
props but he's always
i don't think i did but he's always a
shout out to kendall keller killer colin
he's doing a remember when uh kramer was
chasing
and aaron donald finished with eight
sacks giants lost 56 decided
i think it was 42-2 i mean i don't know
what it was but that was hilarious
tannehill under center first and 10 from
the 19.
pressure to the end zone that might have
been dangerous
my favorite game we've ever done that
was bad
i think there's like two black puns for
a touchdown yeah
titans inside the red zone here need to
come away with points
cut into this deficit and of course
we're rooting for kyle's
second quarter over it i mean a
touchdown here would be great for the
second quarter i mean almost knock it up
all right tannehill completes it break
that tackle
and aj brown his props have to be
looking pretty good he's like three
catches already 31 yards yeah
tanner hill passing yards finally
getting going
[Applause]
third and three at the 12.
titans need a first down here trips up
top henry the lone back
back to throw has time joe new smith
open up top and he looks to run it there
we go
tanny hill this guy played wide receiver
under sherman at texas a
m couldn't that be the difference maybe
and what makes him uh you know he he has
that component to his game he was a wide
receiver when he went to texas
a m yeah and i think you know
he can move a little bit it's it's not
he doesn't lean on that part of his game
but he can do it
he should do it more often i feel like
daniel out of the shot
what are you doing bad spot to be in now
this is tannehill turnover zone
second and goal from the 14. look at
this defensive end he joins the pass for
they faked him out he faked tana hell
out got into his head that was the hot
read
tannehill went away from it
under center second and goal from the
14.
play action henry picks up the blitzers
to the end zone
he was open too but i don't know what
the hell went happened there jesus what
are you
on third and goal from the 14. you're
just you're just hoping for it you want
to just a draw play get better field
position
corey davis or corey davis or joe new
smith
this guy is
shout out to brian ross
this is the first territory crammer
first sir
tana hill out of the shotgun third and
goal from the 14. turnover loading
back to throw has time
jesus oh jesus dangerous throw
just useless horrible ball away
that's what i'm talking about baby now
let's see that john harbaugh special
teams
block kick loading fourth and goal
come out for a 31-yard field goal
[Applause]
and shout out to the brat stop america's
finest brats
delicious bratz and they're more than
just brats cheese is prime rib
prime rib tacos but they got it all all
right
field goals up and it's good now it's a
seven point game and uh shout out to
kyle over in the atc chat he's got nine
more points to go i guess 10 more points
to go
10-3 kramer what what are the uh updated
numbers over at my bookie daddy g
promo code tft
i'm seeing it as 10 and a half
[Music]
plus 630 for the titans can that be
possible no that can't be right
i'm misreading that plus 325. plus 325
for the titans for the titans and
42. a little on that because this game
is far from over
and uh tennessee will hashtag tighten up
i'm calling it plus 325
it's a good ass money line i mean i mean
the
these games definitely have the ebbs and
flows typically we see scoring here
baltimore's definitely the better team
but you know you take away that big play
that's there's not much else to their
game they did convert
a touchdown and tennessee does have a
little bit of that wind at their back so
factor that in when you're making the
third quarter bets because they will
have the win
in the third quarter as well but be
going into it in the fourth
and so far the the playoffs have
gone the same exact way they really
happened so titans maybe
maybe looking for that comeback ingram
oh
there we go football that's what i'm
talking about
it's the way it should be right there oh
here we go they're getting each other's
face
a little chippy ingram picked up too but
he took a shot do you remember
uh cortland was it cortland finnegan yes
and andre johnson with that that game
were they just flat out fought each
other at the line of scrimmage
portland finnegan played they flat out
were punching each other in the field
finnegan played the game right
no suspensions again with the handoff
nothing there loses two and
miles garrett swings a helmet tries to
put miles
i don't even have a problem tries to put
mason rudolph's helmet
i wouldn't have suspended him people
calling for for assault
calling for a criminal shows how
ridiculous our
society societies all right give them a
suspension for a game i don't know
what's crazy is that's not the 50th
craziest
thing that's happened this year lamar
out of the second third and ten
looks to run oh he's so fast oh my
goodness he's so fast
geez 30 yards already all right we're
third of the way there
third of the way through the game i need
a big another big run from lamar right
now
first goal from the 40. he's such a
difference maker
he really is they really figured out his
uh rushing because i feel like before
yeah he wasn't nearly as good you're
right what's everyone got who's sitting
on the first half under here sweet tight
end set
only just one catch let's here we go
that's what i'm talking about baby
that was a dangerous throw by lamar he's
first down into tennessee territory he's
only throwing five passes
yeah that's the scary thing that's why
it's good to have that field goal for
you kramer
keeps them throwing the ball they keep
that ball off the ground
oh what do you mean we have snead did
you take that too
yeah i feel like they put more replays
in the game too
lamar hands it off to ingram nothing
there
second and nine
lamar definitely seems uh they've
definitely juiced his points second to
nine
lamar out of the shotgun
at the 46 of the titans 5 47 left to go
bringing some pressure they pick it up
completes it to the outside
almost broke that tackle got a hold of a
three here
i mean they're looking like a well-oiled
machine right now
duvernay with the grab his second of the
game
lamar not to jinx him hasn't thrown an
incomplete pass yet
not today jason yeah i like what you're
doing there you can our understanding
what you do
now no way no way he throws a pick here
andrew's in motion hands it off to
ingram he could fumble
wow he just like bullied his way for
seven yards
only five are you kidding me second and
five the spots in this game
what up scotty rock for life oh yeah
shout out to that guy
shout out to everyone in the chat love
the chat
big fan of the chat big proponent love
everyone
lamar out of the pistol second and five
uh read option oh
yeah he read that terribly he went to
the outside but i mean got the first
still got the first down
first and ten at the 20. i agree he
could have been still running
lamar vick really living up to his name
racking up these rushing yards
first and 10 from the 20. lamar out of
the shotgun
hard count snead in motion takes it to
seed hands it off to ingram
man they're just 15 carries for ingram
so far that's crazy
only 48 yards though but it's been
jackson's running now it's really
destroyed
some of these drives and we've seen this
in previous games like mark ingram is
capable of getting 35 carries like
three yards and a cloud of dust they're
not afraid to just can
keep pounding the rock
lamar to the shotgun second and eight
from the 19.
high snap ingram again gary
nothing there we needed that high snap
and shout out to waffle doppel over on
the atc
youtube chat thanking us for giving him
the closest thing
to sports well i mean no need to say
closest
thing this is sport you can gamble on it
and
judges are not required that's what my
uncle told me what a sport was
so lamar third and nine from the 19.
bullet pass
income that was dangerous brown would
have caught that he would have tied
his uh what was it three right three and
a half
okay so we've been still you're still
looking good
and another great stop by the tennessee
defense in the red zone
forcing a field goal here keeping them
in this game we gotta force a few
yeah i mean again this is the the reason
why the ravens start
struggle to cover games they just try a
fake last game
yeah he got destroyed 36-yard field goal
is up and it's good
and now the ravens are up 10 but
tennessee has three timeouts
and 224 on the clock so look out
two-minute drill coming here
hashtag tanning time and shout out to
orange and blue
all day i agree fighting is a sport it
does not require
judges we have judges because we don't
want the fight to go on forever
i do but you could settle a fight
without judges
hence it's a sport
so is darts a sport yeah
i think the hard part is where do you
draw the line like i've turned dude i
turned it on espn one time and they had
scrabble on
is that a sport no but it's but yet it's
a board game espn
it's a board game they're endorsing it
as a sport essentially
by it being on espn no
entertainment isn't their name
deep kick and titans titans have the
wind at their back
so could a longer field goal
make it a one score game that would
certainly be uh
a nice move here by them it's been
almost
a quarter since we've seen tannehill do
something horribly stupid
so i wanted to remind you guys that this
is one of those times where you
definitely don't want to do something
horribly stupid
shout out to shaq ttg shout out to y'all
for the stream
the commentary is how me and my friends
watch sports while we bet and i don't
know
makes me want to bet more his name shaq
the big aristotle
and shout out to shaq i mean i remember
the first time i saw shaq
i was sitting near courtside in the nets
game
large man those are free tickets large
man
yeah no waste management a little this
little that jersey
that'll take us to the two minute
warning three-yard loss by henry
tennessee needs to get aggressive he
can't just hand it off to henry a couple
times because
you need some first downs if at the very
least just to prevent
the ravens from getting a fuel going who
calls the next timeout that's the bet
oh tennessee baltimore who's calling the
next timeout
tennessee let's go tani right here
hashtag tanny time
the tan man can oh
to henry baltimore yep
i keep whenever uh derek henry makes a
play i just keep hearing henry
from uh like goodfellas henry henry
henry greatest woman mom mob actress of
all time right
yes though she was great i mean she's in
two great mob cinema movies don't get
better i mean
good fellas just all the times yeah
third and eleven
taney hill out of the shotgun don't hand
it off too
you oh great call great
call
giving it to derrick henry no one saw
him i thought the left guard were left
early like glad they didn't call that
and now
i mean there's plenty of time plenty of
time to get into field goal range they
should be calling the time out there
all right tanning time let's go baby now
i'm running the no huddle they have
three timeouts i would have used one
there oh i like this
tana hill delayed handoff to derek henry
now you have to use the timeout jesus
no they're not going to use them nope
not until under a minute they're not in
scoring position they don't realize that
they
like neither teams what are they doing
they're running the clock out
you dumb
come on hurry up way to show some
restraint there sean
what what did i refrain from saying you
said
10 hell out of the shotgun second and
10. oh
throws it away i'm gonna say he throw it
away he threw it away
are you sure bretty weta say nude for a
subscription
uh sure send us your email and a
screenshot of you subscribing to the
podcast and we'll get you that
nude colby dance photo right away fresh
from bogota
danny hill out of the shotgun big third
and ten they do have three timeouts left
chase oh all right joe new smith
now
there we go north turner play caller
they didn't burn enough clock
they burned a little bit but not enough
move for t
just to say dick dundee
[Applause]
long
all right sean you know we were looking
at the calendar earlier
yeah we were i myself was like holy
it's almost nfl preview time i haven't
even
started reading warren sharp i haven't
even started reading
anything from the football outsiders
well trust me in any real capacity
i guess who's going off the grid for a
little vision quest
a little backpacking trip and yeah i'm
gonna add about a half pound of paper
because i'm bringing some reading
material i know you have a one-way trip
though i'm printing it out i'm burning
it
i know you have been doing much reading
but i'm sure the other nfl teams have
been reading uh joe judge's limited
basic offense
that is just gonna get destroyed from
september
lamar out of the shotgun first oh and
playing action
that's holding snead
[Applause]
what are you talking about dude that was
brutal he's mugging him
just witness a goddamn
brutal
wait hold on girl scout cookies420
interesting use of the 420 badge
wilderness nudes for 25 free play we've
never
oh jesus we've never had such a
sophisticated botch on
i don't know if sneed's gonna hit this
dude they don't he's only had like two
targets i'll tell you what you sl
where where uh slide into the uh the
sports gambling podcast network uh
slack slide into the dms over at
gambling podcast and colby will respond
yeah send it to colby first for
screening purposes
that gambling podcast is how you slide
into colby's dms
lamar under center third and ten here
this is a big play hands it off to
ingram get to the outside
and that's a hold on oh he should have
gone outside more
god damn it tight now they're not going
to use a timeout it doesn't matter
you're good
tony c saying i didn't know this was a
video game for like two minutes thank
you tony
wait hold on this is real it's still
real to me this is a video game
you guys told me this was a real game
what the hell are we doing oh and the
late time out this is not good
now we're in no score zone just a wide
receiver screen to snead let him create
all right how it's too it's too bad
i i it's been a while since we've had no
heart no heart from the spot they went
right for the nudes for free play
first and ten either ravens tennessee
has three timeouts
guessing they're just gonna hand it off
to lamar and take this to the end of the
first half no they're throwing it
dangerous throw to the outside no
timeouts
gosh darn it that'll do it though for
the first half juvenile's getting looks
do renee do they have one more play one
more play it's over
they they can't play they can't turn it
around in 20 seconds uh
yeah you're right got oh oh oh good
thing he was uh calling for that
protection
who's on the sticks who's on the sticks
uh sean who starts with the ball in the
second hand
oh no the ravens another low scoring
affair
it's been great news for the under not
great for kyle he lost that uh 12 and a
half
second quarter over not much to discuss
here the time of possession that could
become
trouble by the fourth quarter if the
titans can't get a little offense going
and ravens haven't turned it over yet i
i think they have one in them you saw
that near turnover that dropped
interception that could have changed
the game for the titans i should have
stuck with my gut and taken uh tannehill
under uh 268 and a half passing yards
vote for t
justice says he'll send nudes for some
snead receptions
okay okay who are you sending them to
because that
that that kramer central on instagram
that's for that uh
for those buffer t justice there's a
different colby inbox that's uh at the
colby d oh man so what are we looking at
here for the rushing yards ingram
seems well on his way to hitting it over
another she's like 88 and a half we
should have known
he gets 30 carries it seems like every
time lamar jackson not on his way
derek henry not on his way as well uh
unfortunately
for colby and i and all of us really
sneed not doing much
well he's still i mean what was the
number again four and a half yeah so
okay the real story 60 yards from
hollywood already he's he's got that
line
yeah and you look at corey davis you
look at brown
you know three receptions 31 yards
they're not far off
uh they're right around the number and
uh jonah smith only two yards on two
catches so
need some uh need some recovery there
anything you want to see
sean do we reinvest in the titans
moneyline magic man blanco wants to know
i i still kind of think this
titans team will get a little frisky in
the second half we'll have to see what
the live money line is but i
i think there could be i i they just
have enough
weapons they're due for a turnover yeah
they're due to get a turnover
and they're they're so they do that's i
meant to get a turnover yeah
well right now it's a plus one
differential
rip groovin 69 wanting to know what the
mark andrews stats were
i think he was a blank right in the
first half i don't think he has a catch
we can we can pull that up though
yeah 0.0
did you take the under uh if you took
the under you're feeling pretty good
right now
kyle's saying quickest most fun way i
have lit 100
on fire in a while well worth it well
again this is
well now it's time to get that money
back
with the second half number over at
mybookie.ag
use that promo code tft look if you have
the titans
are plus three plus 115 on the money
line
this is just for the second half ravens
are minus 175.
23 is the total sean you like playing
overs when that number dips below
24. the team totals titans 10 points for
the second half yes
that's the play people ravens titans
over ten
titans over ten second half you heard it
here first
you heard it here last throw all your
bets light them on fire and just
hammer that tight ravens is 13
ravens get the ball by the way to stp
asking who gets them and
so those numbers essentially adjust the
game to a 13-point spread
where the ravens are favorite and 39 for
your total
you know what sean this ravens team is
going to roll let's go
ravens over 13 points in the second half
[Applause]
and uh let's do it kramer next touchdown
we'll be giving out some my bookie daddy
g
free play all right make sure you give
us a follow on twitter at
gamblingpodcast
subscribe to the sports gambling podcast
apple uh podcast spotify wherever uh
wherever great podcasts are
sold and sean i'm doing an appearance
uh over on par over on catalina little
beach called parsons landing
for a couple days shout out to anyone
who might be out there
yeah nice hopefully i don't see you it's
one of those appearances where i plan on
seeing no one
and i'm gonna read some uh i'm gonna
read some warren sharp do some nfl prep
sean
gonna eat a ton of mgs gonna swim in the
ocean
hopefully see some animals you should uh
are you gonna go fishing at all fishing
is tbd we'll see how much water
sand dabs over there are fire here's
here's the problem with backpacking with
children you have to carry a lot of
that they can't carry
so we'll see the fishing is a tbd right
now but
you ever had sand dabs you know oh yeah
oh yes
the best thing i've ever caught from
this beach is uh sheepshead i caught
about a four pound sheepshead
i'm sure delicious i fried it up i
brought some breadcrumbs with me and
some egg beaters
we've had some great i'm sure shawn has
experienced the uh the fresh fish
oh the frog fish tacos oh yeah you stay
catch yourself
man i i need coleslaw i need to go
i need to go
you're making me want to go right now
because that oh wait hold on girl scout
cookies is trying to trying to dm you
colby it says that he said they can't we
gotta let's let's make sure you follow
this person's
like uh it's it's uh what is this for
the nudes
yeah this is for the nudes um well take
a screenshot throw it in this uh chat
before you yeah
let the dj's have some fun with it
please we're all family here
peace and love peace and love hold on
what's the handle
i don't believe that this is a actual
female for the record no way
i'm saying i'm saying not a female
i don't believe that this is uh this is
a real person
i think we're being scammed my bookie
has player props question mark question
mark question mark
shout out to shaq welcome to the program
we've been talking about it all day
uh for these games they do and and
generally
uh they do for games that we are calling
and sean we'll be back on this not for
atc but we'll be back we'll be back on
the sticks tomorrow night
calling a couple games yeah man tbd if
they'll have player props we'll see
elevate to goat status but the player
props have been super fun i'm really
enjoying the player prop sean
shout out to shaq too one of the best
lines ever charles barkley
mm-hmm he said a as a six year because i
asked for them to get me shaq instead
they got me charles shackleford
no classic line all right are we
what's the time we're kicking off here
does someone have an updated time
you know our boy skeletors always man in
the clock
zajac's saying uh people are all over
the overs where
where's the scoring kramer i i i do
think it will pick up in the second half
but again my big play is
titans ten points in the second half
well there hasn't been a defensive turn
overall game or a big special teams play
there's been one turnover but yeah
you're right yeah first play the game
right
yeah uh yeah i was on third down but um
first drive first drive okay all right
that was almost like a punt all right
we're
force 747 on the west coast
and i i would be concerned about lamar
especially in this third quarter he's
going to be throwing into the wind
uh the wind isn't a huge factor but i i
did notice on that tan hill interception
i think the wind was involved a little
bit so i wouldn't be surprised
at the ravens struggle in the third
quarter get the wind at the back in the
fourth so
that does scare me a little bit off the
titans money line but a plus 400
small sprinkle on that i mean only 25
yards rushing so far what the
yeah they have not been able to get
derek henry going but that that happens
sometimes
all right somebody wants to send us a
message on instagram
[Music]
hello we got a minute left sean
so final answer you're going for the
team total nothing else
let's do it yep team total ten points
lock it up can i throw out an additional
bet for the kramer gang
minus 135 raven score first second
second half
okay i like that they're getting the
ball to start they're getting the ball
to start i think they're
with the wind right is that the wind
direction i forget
what's going on colby oh there you go
man
there you go all right let's see yeah
let's let's uh you know are we ready to
go 747
there you go man
we have been hit up for the nudes yeah
i've yet to see any nudes
call me it says i am though
i i feel like it's a bot right yeah this
is just a really sophisticated ai bot
the cpu is enrolling that process let's
get this game and compute that
i don't have time on this shout out to
shell babe for calling me a buffoon
love you baby hey that that's a
compliment michael
lamar out of the shotgun first and ten
from the 25 come on defense well first
though just lead
who is that incomplete that would have
been brown
hollywood brown had his hands on it
couldn't pull it down
all right i'm feeling good sean let's
close this out with a bang
points are coming points are coming
points are coming hopefully uh hopefully
with a defensive touchdown
from the tennessee titans
oh lamarr checks it down
underneath there who is that did the uh
hayden hearst let's say todd he's right
there anymore yeah
look we're still getting we're still
getting attention here
colby close the deal already he said
don't do me like this
oh yeah it's a dude and i said no thanks
to the dude
third and six lamar out of the shotgun
from the 29.
yeah i don't i mean and lamar looks to
scramble oh so there we go
i mean listen i got a mirror bro you
know
i'm trying to look at a well put
together individual
fourth and four nice three and out by
the titans they'll get the ball back
plenty of time
in the third quarter ravens will be
punting into that win
[Applause]
fourth and four ravens punt that's not
good for my score first no it's not
turnover would be good though shout out
to scotty rock for life
pumping some uh some golf pick sean yeah
where else can you find
golf pits where else can you find sports
gamespodcast.com
sportsgamblingpodcast.com our boys
outside
danny hill under center first and ten
likes that clap
right before he's running he's feeling
good about this jimmy
was doing that too okay oh and down he
goes maybe you don't clap next time
is he injured hopefully he's injured
clay is campbell with the sack bringing
up second and seventeen who's their
backup in tennessee
we're talking about a guy who won a
million dollars on on a golfer
is that what wow golf's big money he's
gonna throw down big bets on golf
yeah you'd be surprised yeah it's like
the third biggest
bet sport tannehill under center second
and 17 from the 13.
hands it off to derek henry nothing
there
have you seen henry really have a
successful guy
lost a yard there i feel like he's
he's lamar jackson where he's just
really good in real life but just
not in the sim world this is great for
my raven score first bet
i i mean they're going to improve their
field position throw it to corey davis
let's go
might even get a turnover here we've
seen
ryan tannehill just give the ball away
third and eighteen
has time jesus cross
campbell two sacks like you're doing a
jig i mean get rid of the ball
you're letting a man do a jig on you
little
how do you get all day just throw the
ball somewhere
that's worse than like being in the
stock cage just let a man
another grown man jig on you why is it
such a short
yeah why why is a lot further back that
looked weird
dangerous looking punt but he booms it
jesus oh my god
randall cunningham back here he doesn't
even pick it up oh my god
from their own fight that's incredible
to the nine
that is a look at this six yard net
punch
drip mr thick dick coming
through
that is the play of the game 86 yards
are you ready
christ he was standing in the
end zone so it's actually longer
no 86 yard net oh net okay 91 grill
lamar pull it pass see ya see ya sneaky
they keep going to this
duvine cha-cha mike devereaux i
don't know
cha cha cha my wife always gets mad when
i uh don't fold the duvernet
that's a married guy humor second and
eight
you get control of your house what are
you doing folding a duvernay show
of course i have no idea what that is
lamar under center second and eight
back to throw not a lot of pressure has
time
why can you not pick one of those passes
off come on
man i mean that punter
so far player of the game mvp for the
for the titans
and we uh expect the leaderboard to be
updated whenever kramer gets around to
it so yeah tonight probably tonight
tonight earlier when he's in catalina
i'm going on a vision quest i'm leaving
thursday morning
everything's done by tomorrow night
thursday there we go baby grab
short of the first down dream scenario
there and the third quarter under off to
a good start
shaq tt we're not doing the game after
this
unfortunately i mean if you put 500
in a uh yeah we will be doing carrier
pigeon
we will be back doing madden sims
tomorrow night though so
tune in eight o'clock east early game
nothing there they never blocked and
sean if you would
actually if you just head over to sports
gambling podcast hit follow you will
you will find out every time yeah we are
on the sticks
or give us a follow on twitter gambling
podcasts that works too
still plenty of time for the titans to
get their together let's go
they really need to get the running game
going take a shot like this dude
plays campbell's look they're not
they're stacking the box because this
fool can't pass
he's got nine rushes for 14 yards
i could do that jesus
how many rushes for how many nine
carries for 14 yards
ah i don't know kramer do you think
colby could do that
just quarterback snake style
just go let me go forward
tan held back to throw second and 14.
throw it
down the field oh my god this offense is
just
trash shout out to jake paquin
you picked the wrong side today boy
[Applause]
you should have you should have joined
the kramer gang
because we're we're going on a heater
shout out to jake
huge friend of the program does a lot of
the cool art for the show
so check him out and he was the winner
of the last tournament we ran
hell yeah college football tournament
cash flow take a shot
jesus christ oh come on
extend it you gotta go for this they're
not going to because they're
cowards danny hill with his best ball of
the day a four yarder
he had that one deep ball and i was
feeling confident i'm like all right
he's gonna be throwing down the field
and reminder championship saturday which
will july 25th
we're gonna have both championship games
and the super bowl six
hours of live non-stop streaming
plus before the super bowl to make sure
we're up for the game
decaf nose beers will be in play
sean has committed we will be doing
decaf nose beers
to pre-game the super bowl we will have
squares we will have props
hopefully we have even more elaborate
props over at mybookie.ag
can't wait will there be a safety all
sorts of stupid
lamar out of the shotgun first and ten
from 20.
hands it off to ingram picks up a
handful there
so sneeze got three catches right now we
need to we need a fourth catch before
this fourth quarter
shout out to eric cargill given the kbo
chat
i love that people just i love i love d
jones like it doesn't matter what we
just need
something right korean baseball
yeah let's go
lamar out of the pistol read option
breaks the first tackle come on not the
second
i need a big rush here i need him to
kind of get loose yeah you're hunched
the yard plays looking a little short i
need him to chop like 30 yards out of it
third and five from the 25 titans need a
turnover come on dude let's go
wow this is where he needs to drop back
just give the impression of a pass and
play action
down the side and that's the
interception
i called it i predicted it i
nailed it
all right we just need at least the
first time oh i don't my first score bet
is ruined
it's ruined don't this up
tanny hill play action oh no he hands it
off to henry picks up a couple i know
that's coming
i know this is their offense is just so
predictable
all right right now it's a 58 yarder if
we can get five yards i feel like there
should be more reaction that i called
that interception i'm not like colby
where i say he can fumble every single
goddamn play
yeah oh wait someone yelled at me for
saying god damn so
what god damn it gosh darn it gosh darn
it
we have listeners in utah checks it down
to derrick henry john what is this
throw past the sticks what is this link
you just dropped in the chat
oh that's uh i meant to send
our uh it's a pretty funny leg
it's something i just retweeted at
gambling podcast i meant to send
why is it not connected dude i almost
said run the ball here run the ball here
it's tan hill third get a field goal
damn it damn it are they in
they might have themselves and
now they're going to give the ravens
better field position will they go for
it
but the win isn't there extreme win it's
still a 57-yarder
i mean yeah i think they can actually
hit this though 58 yarder
they're going for the field goal 58
yarder no he's not getting it
come on he might get this it's up she's
slow
jesus well the guy guy had like an
89 yard punt so let me get this straight
they they get an interception and all
they get is two yards
hey at their 43. suck
the over not looking good baltimore
i mean third quarter under looking great
baltimore to score first now again looks
great
kramer gang is feeling good we're more
relaxed lamar out of the shotgun hands
it off to ingram
and this this titan's offense is just 19
rushes
such dog
have we received the nudes yet no it's
just a dude
why why do you want this dude's nukes i
mean he's excited he's going off the
grid he's going to take it with
him yeah it's called the diversity
you want to diversify your portfolio bro
hands it off to ingram huge hole at the
middle doesn't
take advantage of a terrible vision i'm
following the mick jagger model
whatever works explore peace and love
wait why is someone saying colby
colby's a national treasure
wait what's going on that's pretty high
bar
lamar out of the pistol third and two
from the 44 big third down here they
hand it off to ingram
good pressure it's surely close
first and ten big plugs big play i
thought they were gonna hit him with the
fourth of inches because that was right
there
all right just just gets kneed the ball
what do we need two catches or one
i could afford one loss
i just keep laughing at the story of
desean jackson
visiting now switch like what the
lamar out of the pistol hands it off to
ingram
like all right desean jackson
we've already covered this he's just an
idiot but he's getting
a plane he's going out i mean that's
just watch the ken burns piece dude it's
like
i mean isn't it on netflix
i don't know there's a thing on netflix
and ash well no jeffrey laurie the
the eagles owner is put out a
documentary like
understanding hitler or like how bad
hitler is oh come on we got
this should have been a long hands off
to ingram nothing there well this caucus
he might have gone
he might have got something there dude
sean this clock is melting away
third and five clock continues like a
stuck pig
this thing is bleeding wow third and
five from the 37 baltimore
right in the uh digging range he's
really digging
this is the second this is the second or
third message
oh yeah i'm chatting with you lamar
completes it to hollywood brown
okay so you're a nice team if you listen
to me you at least pushed on that
i didn't end up taking that took the
yard yeah you switched your pick don't
you don't get credit no no i'm just
saying you don't get credit
i think i think some of the listeners
might might oh well
if they went quick on the trigger yeah
they're sitting with extra money in
their pocket
he has two drops too dude that's okay
the live numbers 13 and a half over at
mybookie.ag
from the stream get that screen to
ingram
out of bounds
colby just exploded my head with this
call of screen
32 is the total promo code tft
[Music]
and the net did we get them yet
all right lamar out of the shotgun
second and four from the 13.
checks it down to ingram juke move
nothing there
what was the number on ingram catches
because i feel like he's had a couple he
didn't have one
no but i'm saying oh he didn't have one
and sean the next time we'll be on the
sticks for the atc
the football tournament is friday july
24th
8 o'clock on the east coast with houston
at kansas city
then the nightcap 10 o'clock in the east
coast seattle at green bay
[Applause]
oh mark andrews leads it to mark andrews
for a touchdown
i hate everything i mean come on baby
couldn't have been the snead huh dude
you had to go to andrew the
playoffs are shifting from what we saw
in real life sean
we're getting away from reality right
franco avelia on the uh youtube atc is
calling us herbs
what's that mean uh it's like the term
for losers i
i just appreciate the throwback yeah i
mean what about
what am i wearing the wrong billabong
shirt in seventh grade
you heifer you herb i think this is the
kind of person we call a hand job right
i mean here look dude swallow mike guys
what does that even mean
turkey here's what i'll say that's a
compliment i have some fabulous basil
growing in my backyard right now
thank you he says our voices are forced
whack
why i don't even know is this hello
is this guy a broadcasting coach
[Applause]
well coming from the throat ravens up
20 to 3 here with 150 left to go in the
third titan's gonna need a whole lot of
help
i was all in on them second half team
total over
10 points that's a hell of a backhanded
compliment sean
he's basically saying you sound like a
pro douchebag
nothing is forced dude i'm relaxed
except about my uh titans plus seven bet
other than that i'm pretty relaxed
and i'm nervous about sean jackson
visiting now you might have forced
other than that those are the only two
things i'm really worried about right
now you might have forced up some plates
recently right
yeah it's the only thing i'm throwing up
i yeah franco is uh maybe you were doing
10 miles with 40 pounds on your back
last weekend
oh no that was me sit down
kramer with the backpacking flex in the
broadcast
just a little training follow kramer
center got instagram derek henry
oh yeah there's going to be a post from
my trip finally derek henry
with some positive yardage and a first
down for the titans plenty of time guys
plenty of time
dude this why are we running the
ball throw the ball down the
field
hollywood went over well for what
receptions are yards both receptions
he's tied right now right
three tight end set tana hill under
center first and ten from
37. he's got four right
perks are in motion i don't remember oh
wow play a game can't do that
he's i ryan tannehill i just that face
is really
starting to really starting to chat my
hide
oh sean
what i'm gonna get you some vaseline so
you don't get that chapped tied uh it's
just
gee yeah tana hill empty set
i i mean i didn't even mind when he
threw the interception at least he was
throwing it down field yeah come on
three yard passes i'll take that
at least it's a complete
just picks up seven yards that we need
seven yards that was seven yards
keep getting seven seven yards
and right now if baltimore holds on this
will be the first
of results from a simulated tournament
that didn't match the 2019 nfl playoffs
all right well tan hill back to throw
completes it perfect right
real close to the first down colby does
not like this position
oh no colby sarcastic there yeah
i think uh you know i'm feeling pretty
good and plus i have that
team total for the ravens at 13. we're
halfway home
tannehill go deep i know it's third
inches let's go don't just hand it off
to derek henry please whatever you do
they know don't kill him he's gonna get
shot cash register please
third quarter under third quarter under
for oh first quarter with though right
yep it's all right but we pushed we'll
take it lost the juice
we were 2-0 in the early one i think you
just play that's a long game
you play the long game it's like playing
every first half under in the first
round of march madness rest in peace
tan hell out of the shotgun screen
this finally
finally derek henry the guy who breaks
every attack who breaks the back
how shitty of a play call that was we
got very lucky right there we did
but sometimes it's better to be lucky
than good which clearly the titans
appear to be neither right now horrible
he was about to get stopped
let's go tan hill on the move first and
ten from the 43
out of the shotgun has time
all right please all right just keep
completing oh
now it's like a yard jonah smith that's
clearly two yards
one yard one yard second to nine
i don't know if you're arguing about
smith four receptions though his his
over uh
looking better five and a half was the
number
it's crazy he's going to get there with
that yardage total calais campbell's
been an
absolute terror let's see what he can do
here tana hill back to throw second
night down the field down the
field throw it down the field i hate you
campbell just like played he just threw
the lineman on the ground after the play
now what are they gonna do third and
eight just i don't know
this point third and 18. i don't know
punt the ball i don't i'm so sick of it
he's so afraid to throw the ball down
the field just throw it down the field
sean can i update you with some very
important data
after this play third and 18 from the
49.
the titans need a big play good shot
deep down that sideline yeah goes up for
it
when you throw down field you
hack
colby's telling me i know colby
jesus let's go okay
odd sean a lot like djinn
madness kicked it all off with college
basketball odd is 5-0
in the football odd is sharp
tan hell out of the shotgun first and
ten down the field down the field
has all day jesus i hate you keep taking
the spin move
that's his only third sack i feel like
he's got like nine
colby's very fired up right now i died i
don't like this guy
i i you know i lied earlier i guess i
i'm rooting for him to fail now
yeah i mean i don't know why you did
this to yourself wow they got a lot of
linemen on one side three tight end set
derrick henry the lone pack second by
seventeen and they're doing the
like three tight end it's their offense
nice little completion to the tight end
see uh that's my boy pruitt's nine yard
grab third and seven making it
manageable
just checking in sean the live number
over at mybookie.ag it's 14.
ravens minus 14. 36 is the total
interesting
channel under center third and seven
back to throw you got to throw you got
to throw it he does
and it's incomplete what are you doing
can you do it kick it
make it a two score game gotta do it
what site
is this it's mybookie.ag
and you use the promo code tft you get a
sweet deposit bonus
up to one thousand dollars shout out to
jordan rules the world
ravens minus 14 is money this is a block
kick all over
all over let's go 37-yard field goal
from the left hash
it's up and it's good all right all
right so now we get a hanging
back door field goal with the push hang
back door field goal
i mean it back door i said touchdown
okay and of course
tune in tomorrow night we'll be uh on
our twitch page
streaming some more madden sims that you
can bet on make sure you subscribe to
our
twitch page twitch.tv sports
gaming podcast
yes sean we have some some barn burners
cincy at
indy giants at jacksonville
oh minshumania baby
again you should subscribe to the sports
gambling podcast because
we are about to drop an episode where we
break down
we we dole out a million dollars in
quarterback
season props in the national football
league
he could fumble let's hit this guy from
the 10 juke move
he's taken down 27 ravens
half of the lead up 14. can they coast
to victory
i love the moment where colby goes from
not believing to believing again
it's a big swing all i took was a field
goal it's
it's an emotional roller coaster i get
it we've all been there
first and ten i formation lamar under
center from their own 27.
they're just gonna hand it to ingram
[Music]
there we go
and he's stuck there we go they're all
they're trying to do is eat the clock
two there's ten minutes left they're
just going to play right into our heads
exactly and they're just gonna eat the
clock
we still need to need to get one catch
right i don't know
i don't know if we're getting that one
catch second and nine from the 28.
lamar out of the shotgun
[Applause]
bouncing around nearly caught nearly
intercepted
people are asking what site i want to
play
all you're going to do is go to
mybookie.ag use that promo code tft
and you can bet the live line right now
even if you're just tuning in now
you can still get some money on this
game
kramer what are we looking at working on
it
efforting lamar back to throw third and
nine big third down that's what i'm down
let's go titans come on i love the one
dude who wasn't involved in the play
still flexing
jeffrey simmons with the big dick energy
coming through
come on jeff let's go defense is a team
game
defense is a team game this is starting
to look like
backdoor city it's easy to see a tied
turn
it is easy to see a tide turn ravens
with the punt
deep punt once again oh god
damn it at the there's you guys are in
trouble
you know what though they fixed their
problem too much the problem
is there was a touch back every time now
like everyone drops
inside the five that's great
it's just not if they're aren't they
trying to be realistic any chance
ea acknowledges the fact that they fixed
the game because
people have gambled on it because of the
sim creators i haven't seen the bubble
screen much
no tan hell out of the i formation hand
it off to derek
gets to the outside cuts in are you
doing dancing around he's not a dancer
i know man he's got just five yards down
91 to go let's go
titans nine minutes left sean's a big
titans guy
well when i have money on him yeah
normally i don't
give a is anyone
in nashville care i don't think so tanny
hill
out of the shotgun second and five back
to throw spin move never a good sign oh
checks it down to derek henry what is
this ass offense
how are they so conservative sean the
live number over at mybookie.ag
again use that promo code tft ravens
minus
13 and a half there's some juice on it
though you got to pay minus 175 or you
can take the titans
plus 13 and a half plus 100 one first
down right now money line 750 sean
baby steps baby steve hill back to throw
third and five throw it past the marker
he's open and jesus christ dude
colby's negative energy that's
who you got to blame sean
yeah colby you need like
we need to bring some crystals over i'm
going to steal my wife's crystals and
bring them here rub crystals on colby
titans are punting here i don't know man
at fourth and five maybe you just go for
it
i think he punted that's the play he
threw a pick before he could do it again
give snead a chance to get a catch then
again you gotta punt better than that
though
and it is a two score game so i don't
know i i
fourth and five i think fourth and ten
and more you definitely punt but
fourth and five what are you thinking
right now interception
well first snead four yard pass
they're showing blitz lamar out of the
pistol first and ten from the 46.
[Applause]
gets it off to england oh my god henry's
got room
jeez i can't handle this team i know i
did there's a reason why
i shouldn't bet teams i hate i think
ingram's got to be over right
we need a sneak we do need a pass but
they they're they
they might not need to pass they're not
even good enough to hate them
i don't i just don't like them there's
no purpose for this team
[Applause]
completes it is that hollywood
with the touchdown dude this guy's
having a monster game
and if you had lamar over one and a half
touchdown passing touchdown that's a
pretty nice back door right you were not
expecting it
you're right kramer and shout out to the
guy who threw that out that was plus 140
on my bookie
wow hollywood i i thought hollywood had
four catches
he either has three or four but he has
two drops also but three or four is a
big difference because it's three and a
half oh no i thought it was at three
no it's three and a half huh
everything's uh they're they they stick
to the half so you don't have pushes
because pushes are for losers
right in there with hedging oh god this
is so annoying
well all right so looks like i'll have
the next picture
the snead one's not going to hit now
sean yeah so the next game is houston
tomorrow night eight o'clock
the next game in the atc oh in the atc
tournament
i guess you're right i'll have next pick
tomorrow for the the the regular
the regular non-playoff sim
i'll have a tough decision between
cincinnati
stokey joe and uh phil himself the man
with the most powerful seat in the nfl
there's just slang phillip rivers orange
county or san diego just
making a football team baltimore kicks
it out of bounds
what do you want to see right now out of
your offense john
no jesus conservative play calling wait
you're on the titans or that i know i am
i'm just saying let's maybe you're so
confused
it's so hard to follow a team here
that's the whole point all right okay
you'll never know me all right you'll
never get inside the dante you're like
uh
right you like john wick i understand
tennessee down 21 points seven minutes
left to go
will they throw it past the first down
like they do deep ball
he's got this he's got this he goes up
for it he has his hands on it
at least that's exciting wow if someone
just
someone blew him up you got to hold on
though your first round pick
number five pick i thought he had it
that was a fumble got to get it done
all right same play here we go
tan held back to throw second and ten if
you throw it to the running back checks
it
down to derek henry that's what you want
to do
you're down 21 points take the two-yard
check down
and make sure the clock comes campbell
is a problem
dude he is awesome he's a problem
offense is just brutal
oh you see this
apparently sent two five-star reviews
dylan did is that code for titties
third and eight well i'd rather get that
than uh aj brown's prop
yeah some some random titties aren't
going to push the needle dude i can't
believe the sneak
they scored too too much because snead
would have easily destroyed that
yeah i think we might get lucky though
they generally don't
fully understand they just need to run
the ball until it's it's
really really late in the game so we'll
we'll see if they get the ball back
quickly here you never know a little
defensive
oh i know tennessee's come on
give me this
second half back door oh that's yeah
even better
get another one you oh they
picked it up first down first down right
corey davis second one well and sean
i've already hit baltimore second half
over 13.
that was easy nice
yeah i mean they're they're they're
looking like the number one seed
sean so although we we've had a scare in
both of these games the one seeds are
going to advance
tan hell oh setting up the screen love
that
he's got something he does down to the
32-yard line
are you guys let's get this second half
team total are you still believing yeah
yeah if they get a touchdown here i at
least push my second half team total and
we get a chance of a pick six
i thought it was 11. it was 10. that's
why i loved it
all right sean so what do you need
touchdown are they they wouldn't go for
two so you're good
you'll push at least tannehill out of
the shot under center here we go
to the oh come on
uh johnny smith catch that damn ball
he's gotta
get him off the team they're not pulling
the ball down get him off the team
[Music]
well it's been an exciting night in the
football tournament
it has this game got away from us but
oh and he stays in bounds
no he gets out of bounds my apologies
and they and jonah smith
he's over i think he just went over both
numbers
no not or no he still needs a catch and
a
chunk of yards
sean what was the halftime score was it
13 to three
yeah yeah
that's the play call derrick they want
to run a little clock
picks up one not the
yeah the time management not totally
fixed say that
oh look at he looks yolked harbaugh just
looks extra beefcake
the crowd does not sound as hyped as
they look come on
let's go garbage time right now
second to nine from the eleven tannehill
back to throw he's got him
oh wow that would shoot he threw it to
the wrong receiver he had fertser over
the middle wide open
then he throws in the double coverage
almost throws an interception you just
gotta go over the top there
yeah what kobe said he went for the low
bullet instead of just lofting it to the
back of the end zone easy touchdown
tannehill some sort of bump he's a he's
definite bum
this is this is four down territory
though sean tan hill back to throw third
and nine
has all day to the end zone touchdown
corey davis dude we're still alive
business trip
you're not still alive but the yeah we
are still alive i'll say this
under bettors sphincters are really
tight right
tightening up dude if we get one
turnover there's a chance at uh it's a
little backdoor love
no i mean they have three timeouts
another backdoor
uh touchdown and my guarantee of
tennessee ten points in the second half
cash is
yeah all right and
i i'm with colby like if they get a
three and out of this ravens team ravens
are still
looking at garbage time a push is still
floating around
i love this i love that you guys are
talking your way into this
scenario i'm rooting for it watch it man
he's got a fumble on this kick richard
i'm telling you he could fumble they've
been needing to get a turnover
so it's time has come
[Applause]
we do need a sneak catch though before
that happens just a nice little
bubble screen
[Music]
i think we just need i would love to see
oh on side okay okay we've seen a team
recovered on sidekick will it be the
titans here
jesus no
this is almost good though because maybe
the ravens would try a long field goal
colby
i like what you're thinking do you
believe in miracles
i do i do with two touchdowns for the
back door magnets how do you
know
i mean i'll just take one touchdown for
the battery if they kick a field goal
are you saying admit they miss along
yeah missing a long field come on kramer
you know what it is over 45 and a half
let's go
oh wow they're right i mean sneeds down
here all by himself
ingram with the chicken
couldn't take advantage of it second and
four oh who's sitting on an under right
now
feeling tight load the box load the
box i thought he was gone
yeah i thought it was gonna be a
touchdown he had a hole couldn't take
advantage of the hole
lamar out of the shotgun second and four
did they just hand it to
england are they actually gonna throw
here
lamar back to throw has time steve
andrews stays in bounds alex rodriguez
a-rod
checking in over on youtube asking if
colby dent can please
stop saying he can fumble we have a
drinking game here and we are
up right now you shouldn't have
told me that guys
shouldn't have told you you can't yeah i
mean once the create once you you're
aware of the creator everything changes
lamar
third and three out of the shotgun oh
[Applause]
[Music]
why are they throwing the ball just
rubbing it if there's a tuck if they
throw a touch on the sneed right now
over his very own we still have three
timeouts so we get down score then we
stop who's sitting all the way we're
sitting on an over ticket right now
sneeze right here sneak back to throwing
he wants to run
and he's in the end zone he's not
getting it
wow well that's good for over bettors
you just cashed 46. it's actually good
for us too sean
because we're still alive by them
scoring they're now taking time off
i'll tell you why it's really good it's
because instead of pushing the second
half team total we have a chance to
actually hit it
and that second half over 20 over 23 is
just
the ravens got there almost by them
make sure you tune in tomorrow night
more sim action 8 o'clock east
give us a follow twitch.tv sports
gameline podcast
and subscribe to the sports gambling
podcast
our uh best qb prop bets episode will be
dropping tonight
so you want to have that and a bunch of
really good episodes on the feed jerry
glanville good one
top ten fantasy football running back
quarterbacks all that good stuff
titans down 21 here in
oh baltimore come on bring in the back
up let's see some logan woods let's see
cole mcdonald our guy cole mcdonald
former hawaii quarterback i know logan
yeah
check out our nick rolovich podcast
that's pretty cool dude
all right now to the end zone what are
you guys looking for here you need
two touchdowns for the backdoor push
i'll just take one for the second half
team total cover let's go baby
there's still enough time if they can
score quickly
you guys have a shot overtime loading
overtime loading under bettors just
need to find a spot and uh bad beats
because
how did the undercover give me another
detail
right here throw it
oh nearly intercepted still is able to
derrick henry though
that's the closest he could come to
checking it down
16 points at the half sean and we're
looking at a game with
with 47 right now it's insane
and it doesn't it feel like there's
going to be more points in this one one
way or another
could be second and ten
[Applause]
under center checks it down to adam
alfred's juke go backwards side step
always a good idea
[Applause]
still got all three timeouts cream are
you a little worried uh
yeah i'm worried for you guys because
you still believe and
you're just gonna be heartbroken that's
that there's nothing more to it
we're going to take a step down with
dude
they're negativity 17 and a half but you
gotta lay three minus 300 for the ravens
titans
plus 17 and a half plus 150. uh
let me see after this play i'll tell you
oh jeez
i'd lay the 17 and a half and people get
it in
although they're going for it on fourth
down it's almost better
yeah low get that minus 17 and a half if
you can
i mean don't overthink this let's do our
one of our classic three
three or four yards passes you know
actually let's make it four yeah
and uh pick six danielle back to throw
fourth and four
complete sits i mean where's that all
game
well he's got to be over right jj brown
over there he's had a good game yeah
that was a guy to target in these seven
for night that's got to be over
yeah he's over both he has like 50 of
the receiving yards
he's having a game someone had to step
up
i mean they're they're only down 21
points i i did suggest
corey davis under tana he'll stop the
move hits derek henry in stride down to
the
floor still alive don't call the timeout
go go go go go
come on oh first dance
celebrating now they're showing a replay
[Applause]
killing the club you gotta wonder if he
just breaks that tackle
does he have enough speed to get around
the engine finally
right now right now they gotta go deep
tan hill out of the shotgun first and
ten from the 40.
back to throw gets it off to jonah
because i think that just put jones
smith oh my god kramer i'm about to hit
uh
over ryan tannehill passing yards are
you really why would you just choose one
because they're so far down i
think it doesn't matter
but they're still running the no huddle
it's kind of a confusing message to send
to your fans
danielle out of the shotgun out of
bounds
why would you do that call timeout
tandem hill hit it
he hit the over passing yards like they
called timeout now
so they let a minute go off the clock
before
i don't know i don't understand this
how did you hit that i have no idea
they must have how did you hit that
because i forgot that
sacks count away from team passing yards
but not individuals
i mentioned they have like a hundred net
yards
he's been sacked so many damn times
all right taylor out of the shotgun
first and ten from the 26.
[Applause]
back to throw come on second half team
total let's go
checks it down to humphreys gets out of
bounds okay now you're at the 18 you
have two timeouts
you have four shots just get it in the
end 47 attempts and only 13 points
that's insane that's a crazy ratio count
hasselhoff
dick is safe dick will live another day
got to go to the end zone here no if
ands or butts
out of the shotgun second and two from
the 18. well at this point i think
they're doing on sidekick anyway so
get rid of it time out time out
oh is this going to end like this oh you
got to be kidding me
is this going this is going to call it a
timeout
we got a second half deep total to catch
you losers
it's going to be after the commercial or
after this they're going to call it
oh this is dramatic to the end zone
taking a shot
well at least he got to the end zone and
at least he hit his over
passing yards
units are mine sean hey dundee's still
done he's still five and two on the
night all right
gobble gobble gobble as they say
in blacksburg
give me those units a lot of fun action
a lot of excitement here
make sure you give us a follow on
twitter at gambling podcast subscribe to
the sports gambling podcast
apple podcast spotify wherever great
podcasts are downloaded
check us out on the old gram and tune in
tomorrow night we'll be doing some and
all things comedy tournament that the
leaderboard will be updated
uh by tomorrow yeah before i go on my
vision quest
yes and a lot of good stuff coming up
over at sportsgamblingpodcast.com tons
of free content and once again
thank you for participating in the
sports gaming podcast and for
the sports gaming podcast i'm sean
stacking the money green and he is ryan
i'll see everyone tomorrow night john
kramer let
it ride
so
[Music]
you